Harley thing's YouTube channel and
welcome to the pregame
[Applause]
I agree with you I think they do do it
for the men but it's like sexual tension
it's not a relationship attention so you
can kind of do a cheat code you can go
get a BBL get a nice body and you do get
more attention from men than if you're
flat right but here's the thing though
no no but but listen though if it goes
so deeper though because I know what
you're talking about and she has a great
body yeah so you got to think about how
far down deep that she is within
watching the Instagram models within
watching The Cosmopolitan magazines
great body it doesn't look good to a man
but you think that men have higher
standards for women not that the men
have the higher standards they have to
live up to just to clarify I think men
have highest ends for women for women so
like the women have higher beauty
standards to me yes and that's what's
making women feel like they need to
comply with these standards who's
pickier men or women men women are more
complacent than men
are more complacent yeah I think they
accept all of them and yeah I think men
are very like if they're they've got a
certain standard they're more rigid than
women I think men are pickier than women
100 definitely but they will not marry
it they will not settle down with
somebody with a focal lipstick eyebrows
and if they do it ain't gonna last so I
I done an only fan but it wasn't like
vagina boobs it was lingerie yeah feels
great whatever I'd done it and when I
finished it I felt very degraded I felt
very like why did I actually do that now
I know there's girls out there who do
that they don't feel that way that is
perfectly fine you do you you feel the
way you feel but me personally like like
in the future how like when I have kids
and all in the future and if my kids
found out about that they'll probably
get bullied in school there are people
like oh your mom doing this your mom
doing that and your man as well he's not
going to if you don't respect yourself
and you're selling your body online I
can't speak for everyone I can just
speak for myself if you're selling your
body online like that there's not
there's not a high respect for yourself
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
[Applause]
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that we are going to
be notified of my daily videos like the
video on your way in as that is the most
important metric that YouTube uses to
push out these videos
um also if you as you already know if
you have watched two or more of my lives
and you don't subscribe we have beef
okay beef people
um a couple announcements before we
start the show um the first is that all
super chats over blessing what do you
want to do today all super chats over
what are going to be read 20. all super
chats over 20 will be read tonight
um and also guys we have four membership
tiers um how many likes to open up the
chat tonight blessing 1.5 1.5 000 likes
to open up the chat so make sure you
like the video also guys um we have four
membership tiers the first tier you get
to be a part of the chat the second tier
you get to see are discordner behind the
scenes blogs if you want to see me
freestyle rap sign up for the second
tier um third tier you get to connect
with me on social media and fourth tier
you get a one-on-one call with me once a
month do you want to know how to get a
million subscribers in a year sign up
for the fourth call also guys follow my
Instagram they took away my first one
just pearly things one um
if you have anything you want me to
react to or um I don't know stuff you
guys want to send me send it to me on
there also guys subscribe to wife school
we just dropped um what to cook your
husband in a day so go check out wife's
school also guys we have an animation
Channel just pearly animations and
um follow our two talents Auntie Jenny
and King Richie's and yeah okay thank
you
um so um today we have a lovely panel
including some special guests um so why
don't we go around everyone say your
name your age your relationship status
and a fun fact so starting here go
around in the second row so my name is
cintish most people might know me as
brown and bougie I am 23 I'm also single
and a fun fact about me there's nothing
really that interesting except I love
Jesus and I'm a pastor's child yep
that's it
um my name is Danielle I'm 22 from
London
um I'm single and a fun fact
um
I don't I don't know
so many times you didn't come with a fun
fact
I'm currently training to be an
esthetician okay go ahead
my name is Kim
cash I am a London rapper
um I'm 25 and a fun fact about me
is that I'm way too sexy for this world
oh no she's back I had a lot of people
message me saying denalva please come
back well I am back then not looking for
trouble uh fun fact you're not looking
for trouble you know I don't you're not
sweet and innocent yeah yeah
Sarah is a girl's name
she's lying about the trouble though I
asked her if she's a feminist and you
said no I'm just looking for trouble
yeah
yeah and then the camera's turned on
yeah I do look for trouble I'm joking
they know
it's my turn yeah I'm snico I am 24
years old and fun fact I am a really
nice guy
yeah
I didn't like that at all
it's nice to see a nice sweet side if
you're a nice guy means that
vulnerabilities
oh nice guys finish last no that is but
nice guys and nice husbands
you go husband can you cook
do you want a husband that cooks no I'm
just asking if you can cook then I've
got a line to say after obviously
I can't cook but I won't cook oh that's
okay I got you okay
girls that's how you do it how you do
what not get a husband no that's how you
freaking get yourself out of the bad
situation because you said why'd you ask
so I said because I've got line after
trouble
Jaguar 37 nothing to say
no fun fact
fun fact it's not that's not that fun I
know but
it's okay um second row go ahead my name
is mecom21
um I'm gonna recycle the fun fact I used
last time I like to shoot guns
um hi guys my name is Chelsea Cecilia
I'm 19 I'm from London and a fun fact is
I want to be a TV presenter
Troy Francis 47 years young I'm a dating
coach based in London and a fun fact I'm
single as well fun facts about me I've
written 11 books about dating and the
dating Marketplace
so
thank you all for coming today's topic
I'm just going to get right into it do
feminists crave destruction yes explain
it right here just uh we started up the
show with destruction ask me the
question and then you'll see
okay so she said you said yes why yes
because the whole point of feminism is
to eradicate the importance of men and I
didn't see anything as destructive as
eradicating the importance of men in
society that's a simple way to put it
what do you think I agree with what
she's saying a hundred percent did you
actually agree are you just trying to
get to the next person no I agree with
what she's saying I think that a lot of
I think the term feminism has been
almost changed in modern day time and
made into almost like women need to
overpower men and women need to take
over the world kind of energy
I hear that not I don't agree
okay what do you think
um feminism
is made to empower women and show men
the importance of women in society
what's the importance of women in
society
society we also say
but it's not that what's your importance
what's your role in society if it's so
important if you're that's the point of
empowering you
what's your role
well I'm not being funny
um without where would the world be
without women like where would you
you've come from a woman
you've learned most of what you've
growing up people you up was it your
mother or your father who's so who's got
core duties why do men go so hard
so the importance of a woman is
motherhood no not just motherhood
come back to me I have to think about it
but women you seem pretty set in stone
on that I think we just
saw feminism in real time you said that
it's in our role is really important and
then you just said motherhood which is
that existed before the feminist
movement motherhood has always been
important it's always been respected
you're right and it's Pinnacle how do
you think the world's going to continue
to go on without motherhood we agree so
would you be here if you didn't have a
mobile we agree 100 exactly so what is a
feminist movement done to prove that
well the feminist movement if you're
talking about what um
you'll see it what's going on now the
empowerment all this girl boss thing
that's going on right now no that's
modern feminism that's what it's evolved
to but feminism in itself is made to
make the world see the value I used to
plan assassinations in the early 1900s
well um
yeah artist terrorist groups that are
men and women you know it's equality
isn't it movement can be terrorists too
true that's why I think feminism in my
opinion
is the problem when people want to label
things you don't want all of the same
things we're all very different women we
have different experience different
careers different ones so if you start
saying feminism you start labeling
everybody it's a problem because a black
woman's freaking experience is not the
same as a white woman so we are feminism
doesn't look the same so when everybody
say no women Empower yourselves we can't
Empower ourselves the same way some
women work some don't so with a mother
some women are not mothers he's like
don't put me under the same what is a
black woman what does that have to do
with feminism it has to do with feminism
because for example for me just knowing
the difference between between my
empowerment and the empowerment of my
white girlfriends it's very different I
have bigger struggles to overcome so
when somebody's telling me all feminism
Empower yourself we're all the same no
we're not we're quite different the same
way that I don't believe that racism is
actually something that many people
should be speaking on because even that
black experience is totally different
depending on where you're from what
class you come from so women are not all
the same just because we are women this
is like everything you're saying is why
people think that feminists are just
chatting because like what does racism
feminist so I don't really care and I
brought feminism as a as a comparison
point because I'm just trying to explain
that when you put people in the same bag
every single time it causes problems so
you don't actually get to understand
what the genuine problem is and you
start saying oh we want this but then
you don't know what it's victim mindset
yeah it's it's having a victim mindset
I'm black I'm a woman I need empowerment
I need victimization is a fact because I
know I live that experience you may not
and on top of that I'm also an immigrant
so I already know that my experience is
different so when I'm talking about
empowerment
a lot of ways you're victimizing
yourself I'm not victimized I'm
empowering myself because I'm a G I made
it through the problem
probably care about whether or not it
was a situation but that's working to
see you Empower Yourself by victimizing
yourself I found myself by understanding
that perhaps I may have a bigger Hill to
climb so I'll train harder it's what
you're leading with though it's
certainly what you're leading with your
race your gender and your and your
immigration of course you're leading
with that is that your identity you can
understand that when I'm a feminist
student what about what you've done in
the world instead of all these other
things okay then why not leave with
those I'm an educator as well okay and I
understand the difference between me
going into that that job versus other
people I work with different types of
racism what I'm trying to say is I'm not
trying to make this about racism I'm
simply making a comparison to expect but
you did no no I certainly do and let me
tell you why because I'm making a
comparison so it's an analogy to explain
another problem when you put everybody
in the same basket it doesn't work
that's why feminism doesn't work it's
not a good thing because I don't relate
to feminists because the problem is not
just caused by gender the problems are
caused by these other factors that
you're talking about yes but it's caused
by so many different things there's
different elements to it so don't box me
in so that's why I don't think feminism
is good you neglect the people that
actually do need empowering and I don't
think it's fair to say that she
shouldn't lead with her race and all of
these things because when you look at us
the first thing you do see is my race if
I am a TV presenter you're not gonna
it's the first thing I see that's the
first thing you say when I see you I see
a woman I don't see a black girl maybe
that's just you but the majority you're
gonna already have this stigma of me
because I'm like here's the problem with
you doing then I say this with love but
if you have that top of mind all the
time you're going to suppress yourself
but that's literally that's life like
that's gonna you're gonna suppress
yourself you can't change it and that is
like that's like me assuming that y'all
are gonna hate me because I'm a straight
white male why would I think that about
you guys when we could just get along so
I don't understand like why
why
your empowerment movement is is not the
same as mine so don't actually label me
to be in that situation and say oh women
want oh I'm not labeling you I'm simply
telling you what exactly what you said
no no no no exactly what you said what
do you think about feminine I said I'm
black I'm an immigrant all this [__]
that's literally what you just said
that's exactly okay let me rephrase it
so you can understand that okay so
essentially if I stand next to a
feminist yeah for example a white woman
I don't relate to you because okay wait
wait wait let me finish can I finish
you're about to say I can't box myself
in with you because I'm glad that's not
what I'm saying say it then what I'm
saying is I am not the same woman as you
what I want and what I see to be
empowerment is not the same whether it's
culturally whether it's racially whether
it's professionally academically
personally whatever we are all very
different women cannot be boxed into the
same box because we're not the same
because you're in different races
because of different experiences as
women so you're making an anti-family
you're making anti-feminist argument you
want to have other you want to have
other things I've got I've got a lot of
victims balance yeah I know the things
that are not right and I know the things
that are right it's not just black and
white there's gray areas in the middle
that's why I mentioned for example
things like race is a gray area in the
middle that makes it say oh yeah
feminism may not actually be as accurate
as people are saying that is why people
come across feminists and they don't
know what they want because one wants
this the other one wants this and the
other one wants this because they are
different and that is why feminism in my
opinion is destructive and I don't think
she's playing victim I think she's just
acknowledging a serious issue in Society
racism yes are we gonna act like racism
doesn't exist yeah racism is not a
problem that's how they keep people
broken at the bottom and arguing about
nothing and thinking that they're
victims sounds like a problem it's not
it's not a problem when you believe it
you're it's the problem then isn't it
okay my point is your existence is a sum
of your beliefs and your thoughts and if
you're always thinking that I'm a victim
because I'm black I'm not a feminist
because of this I'm an immigrant then
you know what's gonna happen you're
gonna stay poor you're gonna stay
unhappy and you're gonna see racism
everywhere at a certain level of wealth
and at a certain level of status people
never discuss things like race people
never discuss like I'm an immigrant so
it was hard you just want to get to the
next Point yeah that's why racism
winners only see green because the truth
of the matter is like I own a business
right a bunch of employees if somebody
turns up and does their job and they're
profitable for my company I cannot
afford to give a [__] about their race
religion hair gender any of that stuff
because it's too hard to find people
that work really hard so a great example
of that is LeBron James has been in the
NBA for years because he puts out
[__] results okay and he's not
worried and he's not worried and living
oh I'm black I can't play in the league
but you could say that for any I know
plenty of successful young black men and
one thing I have a super big heart for
is I play college football and I cannot
stand to see people put those young men
in a box and tell them from the jump
that they are not going to have a good
shot at life just because they're black
can I ask that is putting them in a box
from the beginning and lying to them
sorry this
had the same Journey as his white
teammates
that's what white teammates you want to
talk about exclusion how many white
people are in the NBA I can't think of
one no no yeah name a white NBA player I
feel left out [__] this I'm leaving no
no no but I'm just saying if okay
actually that's in America and you in
the in the UK it's different my problem
is he's telling young black men that
they don't have a shot because they're
black is literally handicapping them
from the jump and I won't stand for it
in the UK it's very different my friend
in the UK for example the football
leagues they are full of white boys and
the white players are actually quite
physically endowed and they're quite
talented they get they stay behind a
little bit more they're not selected
first in the UK it's very different
that's why I say you should unbox people
in and talk about generally because
culturally [__] though I'll tell you
why I tell you why it's true an owner of
a bit of a company whether it's a sports
team or a normal business cannot afford
to choose somebody or not choose
somebody based off their race or gender
but that's not true because no let me
tell you why because the way that you
make money in the sport is you win
[__] championships Virginia
UK yeah they don't get the ratings for
example in the World Cup three black
players scored but when they were when
the England was eliminated from the
World Cup those three players were the
ones that were blamed and all the white
players were the ones all celebrated
because that actually does happen in
this country so that's why it is
actually important I don't know anything
about it but I'll say this sorry so I
bet with you trying to say racism
doesn't exist
you believing that your victim holds you
back more than any of the actual racism
this is some it's really just poor
people coping that like racism this is
why I'm not successful this is why I'm
unhappy it's because of systematic
oppression that mindset will hold you
back more than any white system with
that mindset that mindset will hold you
it's gonna hold you back way more than
any race I will say is racism does exist
absolutely it resists everywhere exists
it exists everywhere but obviously I
wouldn't call myself a victim I've
experienced racism but I don't say I'm a
victim I wouldn't I wouldn't let that
stop me from
prospering do you have a harder time
succeeding than a white girl
I don't know I feel like it's all about
mindset to be honest okay if you if you
sit there and think oh I can't do this
because of this or I can't do that then
obviously that's a negative mindset to
have you're not going to grow and you're
not gonna it's all about the best
version of yourself but if you think
okay I might be different but that's not
going to stop me from elevating and
being the best version of myself
I get what you guys are trying to say in
terms of my mindset I definitely believe
that what you think is what will
manifest but what I'm trying to
understand is are you guys trying to say
that racism does not exist at all and
it's just this fantasy not as much as
we're talking about it right now and not
as much as the
and as much as feminists believe that
feminists like are held back and that we
need to be empowered to ask like what
how do we Empower women oh motherhood
okay mothers have always been respected
so it's a lot of this people like to
have and this is what wokeness does we
like to have reasons to justify our
existence and where our place in the
world like we're held back because of
white oppression I'm a feminist I'm an
immigrant and this is why I'm where I'm
at it makes us feel better about our
position in life but if you let go of
those attachments and just understand
that the world is what you make it you
will succeed and you will be better
these ways so like racism it's all
garbage it's all meant to keep us like
down and at the bottom the black lives
matter movement for example was all
garbage all psyop although it was a scam
same with the feminist movement any of
these ideologies that people grasp on to
feel better same thing with all these
people talking about Ukraine and Russia
like you're not going to change it just
go get some money and start a family and
just stop attaching yourself to stuff
that you have no control over and that
and that's the point and he's dead on
because like for example
um people get all up flustered about who
wins the presidency oh Trump's present I
can't dude I don't give a [__] who wins
president you could be president
tomorrow I'm still going to win bet your
[__] ass I don't care what the
condition is I don't care who's in
office Dude any of you could be
president tomorrow and I'm still going
to get them go to work the next time can
I tell you something very interesting do
you know why racism actually exists
because nobody said it didn't no wait
wait it's not a way to lead your
identity he's actually very annoying
because what people don't understand is
that sometimes you're walking amongst
black people or even sometimes a black
person will go into a shop and the
security guy will look at them and
follow them they don't even know they're
looking at Prince because they don't
have a black person no these the only
problem pattern recognition no no listen
listen yeah the problem is that with
this whole idea of racism what people
talk about for me I find racism to be an
insult because people look at the skin
the color of my skin and they assume I'm
lower than what I am actually but no
they don't no they actually they do they
actually do
but coming from the two girls that
brought our braids though that's the
thing you bring a brace immediately the
show been going on five minutes because
you both bring up black I never seen
never in my mind
can I ask you a question
um you said it like they who is they uh
just overall the general population in
this country at least
would you say like everyone in this room
I don't think that's true I don't think
that's true in London
I'll explain to you why they hear my
accent a lot of the time they see my my
skin I just want to know who wait wait
just people in general so I Met You in
London so I'm asking you like that is
that this room is that like everyone in
here just met you today they I mean this
is the people that don't mind me I don't
need to know this this is and I'm just
saying this is a good sample size of
people these are all random people like
okay you know and I know we know each
other but of course outside of that I
relate to a lot of these girls could you
be projecting insecurities onto other
people they're making assumptions about
what people think about you because when
I met you I didn't think I didn't think
oh she's lower or she's anything else
you know whatever I mean I just thought
yeah cool girl
I'll explain to you why and this is the
same thing with then that goes perhaps
that links more into feminism is that I
just don't like the fact that people
assume less of my capabilities based on
something I don't know
I'll tell you who her she's the one that
put it out in the universe let me tell
you let me tell you it's not this is
Victor mindset literally what she said
it's not listen listen my biggest
comments yet guys you guys are
Troublesome my biggest comments is like
look at this stupid girl what does she
know I thought Mr King riches that I
could fix a Bentley and he laughed well
how could you be white because I'm a
girl that's the thing so feminism what I
think feminism is King riches why not
say it but why not respond to King rich
and say because I have the skill set yes
and that's the whole point doesn't
that's why feminism as well what the
girls are trying to say what is the
point listen listen you know what I
believe girls are trying to say is that
listen don't look at the fact that I'm a
girl I've got the skill set so respect
me for my skill set that's in lead with
it that's it lead with that I have the
skills of course and the only reason why
I mentioned my brain is to separate
myself
let me just call space
us choosing not to get that skill so
people assume that but I don't know how
you think that to me saying that
feminism is Holiness no because you were
you were saying that like people assume
that you couldn't fix a BM or so people
assume that you couldn't fix a BMW yeah
and somehow that's tied to fam who cares
so no it doesn't matter
Girls just want credit for what they
can't do I will give you 200 pounds if
you can fix a BMW we can do the video
stay tuned
I'll match it I'll match it because I
love that and if you can no I'll match
it yeah
make sure that you subscribe to my
channel
and watch me fix the car I fixed it you
change battery strange tires fix the
Electric System why because I know how
to use Google very well and I practice
and I did it love it love it I think
anyone who hasn't experienced racism
shouldn't say anything about it full
stop okay cool so I agree quite a while
five years five years in a black
neighborhood I got in a fight every
other day for it okay but because I had
red hair they called me a rooster I
literally got in fights every day so you
got bullied that's not racism exactly
discrimination based on what it is
exactly where racism is it's not racism
he wasn't oppressed we were the ones
that oppressed so you can't call it out
how are you oppressed in 2023 how are
you oppressed because I got news for you
honey if you had a skill set that was
worth something to somebody you would be
the richest [__] in here so say we
didn't exist that slavery exists slavery
exists yeah it also it also existed for
virus I'm not trying to belittle what
happened I would never no I'm not no I'm
not UK talking slavery no no no no no
here's why there was no slaves here
here's why no this is very important can
we stop this is very important to me I
have a lot of young black men that
follow me there's no [__] way on
Earth I'm gonna let them believe that
they have a lesser chance than anybody
else if they just work their ass off
there's no [__] way I'm not sitting
on their dreams like that I'll be damned
you call me a racist if you want fine
but we have to call me a racist all day
I'm not I don't care there's no way I'm
letting those young men believe that
[__] 100 because I know plenty of black
guys look King rich is here right now is
a [__] winner all day long because he
didn't let that [__] happen 100 we have
to work hard enough what about threat
what about all of our friends that are
black that are very very successful
looking at racism it's for broke people
I just finally insulting don't it's not
it's not insulting you lead with it get
a new identity
I'm a black girl you're so much more
than that you're so much more oh yeah I
know then don't leave with us it's
[__] this [__]
I use it as a comparison for me to
explain why I'm not the same as every
girl that puts themselves in one thing
and tell us the skills you have and the
person you are that why don't you lead
with that because
it's given that you guys hate women
that's that's the Vibes right now
wait wait wait we have to do one at a
time stop just stop stop can I say
something it's not a thing where they
hate women if anything they love women
for a man to tell you to think
positively how was that hatred the
people are literally telling us that
what we think is what's going to
manifest so therefore think positive
thoughts and positive things will happen
to you you guys on this table who are
talking about feminism you're all
negative because why would you focus so
much on comments why would you focus so
much on who's looking at your hairstyle
your accent or whatever and then someone
comes to tell you actually focus on the
positive and you guys are saying they
hate you no no you can't focus on it
just the other day a man applied for a
job and they told him he can't get the
job because of his afraid so you can't
tell us to not focus on it when it is
the focus yeah and watch the news it
literally happened the other day yeah
but that's his experience but if he was
smart he's not gonna let that hold him
back that's the whole point from the
news
you can't tell us to not focus on it a
certain place of my afraid the first
thing people are going to do is stare at
me and certain places won't want to give
me the job just because
stop wait thank you do you know why you
saw that in the news
because they want you to believe that
racism is a real problem it wasn't even
underneath so you're lying she just said
that it was a Windows
it went viral on Twitter let's fact
check though I said it was on the news
no but you're saying on the way you saw
it on the news yeah that's why I saw it
so you're adding to it they share these
stories like George Floyd and like that
afro nonsense that you saw on the news
in order for you to believe that there's
a system that's holding you back it's
not and you saw here we're talking about
race hold on so the man went online and
was like I didn't get the job sat there
and didn't have it at this point when he
was taking chose to run that story
because it gives people like you a
reason to feel people like me exactly
people like you know they used to want
to give my mom free food in the market
because they didn't believe that white
woman could have three little kids and
have fruits they used to give her food
because they used to think that were
little African children that suffer
these times we're quite wealthy so for
example okay my overall point is that
people like to have a victim mindset
especially victimization I'm just saying
he exists okay that's it that's my point
is that we hear this victimized mindset
right now in order to give you a way to
navigate the world that justifies a lot
of your thoughts and beliefs we're
talking about race and you're like it's
giving misogyny no you
you're just calling out the
victimization of the race you feel the
vibrations of misogyny of yeah of your
mentality your mentality is one of your
type of man that's what what type of man
no sister they're just here trying to
make you look stupid that's what their
job is that's not that hard it's not
that [__] hard don't take it personal
they literally just want to cut you out
I'm asking I'm trying to get to what she
really believes King Richard's trains me
for this all right what what are the
vibrations that I'm giving you that is
given misogynist why what did we say I'm
not being funny if what what value do
you see and what what how do you value
women do you see the value of women like
like you I explain it five minutes ago
you didn't I said that I'm against
feminism and I said that yeah but if
you're gonna call him a misogynist if
she asked me a question I said the value
of a woman is motherhood is in raising
children I said that we respect mothers
I opened the show by saying that okay so
what did I say that makes you think that
I'm a massager that's a serious
allegation
I said it's given misogyny what is
giving massages no vibration my
vibrations you're vibrating misogyny
right now so are you vibrating with
racism too like what goes on and when
we're moving a little bit mean that's
why I'm moving a little bit now you're
trying to put your message
yeah I can feel it and it's like you're
trying to suppress my feminine it's it's
true
he's trying to suppress your [__]
like come on bro y'all look y'all all
smart pretty young women you can do
anything you want to in this [__]
world and my message is this Oprah
listen
[__] here's the thing and you swear a
lot I do a lot I'm sorry I do I know I
do I'm gonna keep doing that so here's
the thing I just there's no planet where
I'm gonna allow it particularly a young
black man to think that man young white
man yeah go one because
we're talking about race particularly
right now and I like well there's no
planet
do I want to ever put out into the
universe are allowed to be put out in
the universe that a young black man is
going to not be able to be successful in
his life because of his skin color
there's no chance and I will sit here
and and you can call me whatever you
want but I just know too many of them
and I know too many have been successful
yeah but you're one of a few you're not
but like the majority you have to
understand how many people watch his
show can I how many people watch her
channel it's important no you're not
okay I understand that but in general it
does it doesn't stop you but it does
make a little challenge
can I he's like he's like you're one of
the first white men that I've met who
have this mentality maybe it's no no no
no no you know what I honestly I think
most white people
prejudices exists maybe not racism let's
adjust the word not racism Prejudice is
something different I do I believe that
and I think there's Prejudice all over
the world
negative countries like lowly sure and
in countries like Japan that are very
you know homogeneous homogeneous they
won't even let you in the restaurant
unless you're Japanese like you guys you
think you've seen racism bro there's
some places in this world I've been that
are turbo racist outwardly and get away
with it I think a black person today has
a better chance than they've ever had is
it completely Fair no I don't think so
but I don't think life is completely
fair at all and there's no way I'm going
to let somebody mentally handicap
themselves from the jump and you know
about me I don't I don't think it's an
impairment to me I know it made me it
made me a bit stronger but I know exists
and for you it's a superpower yeah right
that's it I just want to reframe it
thank you and have a different
relationship with it but for me
independent woman because she because
she led with it
she said she's leaving yeah but it
didn't sound like a superpower then did
it no because you didn't allow me to
finish you start saying you're leading
without what does that have to do you
became challenging and this is the
problem this is why she said you got
guys are feeling a little bit like
misogyny but that's not what she means
no no you're gonna be very aggressive
they're just talking about pressure
because it's important it's important
because you have to go out into the
world with the absolute mindset that
regardless of your circumstances
regardless of your background or your
racial um ethnicity or anything that you
can go out and you can make a success of
your life we all have to do that 100 and
that's why they're getting so passionate
about it you know it really is it's
really important exactly no he's dead on
you know what it looks nice really what
real love looks like in my opinion Real
Love is dark and Real Love Takes risk so
let's say you're [__] up let's just
say it was racism I'm willing to step in
front of you and have you be angry with
me so I can somehow change where you're
[__] up and you can be mad at me if
you want because most people people
don't give a [__] about you will let you
leave and be like that [__] is [__]
up I would much rather get into a heated
argument with you and have the courage
to sit in front of you and tell you my
truth and have the thought of somebody
thinking that I'm racist on the internet
I'd rather do that than let the young
men that follow me believe they don't
have a shot I'd much rather sit in that
and to me that's the only kind of
friends I want it's people that are
going to tell me the truth when I'm
[__] up so you get mad at me but I
just hate to see it led that way I'd
much rather hear about the skills you
have and and I'm with you Pearl I'll
I'll triple it I'm gonna say Well done
to my skills so you can say go [__] yeah
[__] yeah
you just got women privilege
in dollars to see if you could fix the
car that's what I'm saying it's a
superpower should I take it black
because you're a black girl don't take
it back
actually do you hear the the black
privilege sure I peeped it a little bit
earlier black people and minorities in
general have more freedom of speech than
white people because you just said that
in my experience white people aren't
like this and he's the first white guy
you've ever seen act that way you're
able to say and that's uh that's pattern
recognition if we if a white person said
the same thing that would be seen as
racist you can't make judgments about
other minorities like that white people
have the least amount of freedom of
speech right now because immediately and
especially like right now you call it
saying that you're vibrating with
misogyny because I'm speaking
aggressively towards you that victim
mentality gives you a lot more free
speech than you're really aware of well
if I say something that upsets you it's
misogynistic if you see patterns in
different races that's just seen as your
your world view if he said the same
thing oh you're the first black girl
that talked that way in my experience
you would call him a racist yeah he
makes a good point because if somebody's
if one of us guys said oh this woman
over here she's she's I can feel the
vibration of her toxic femininity you
know we'd just be like canceled
immediately not really no they were just
called us [__] that's just a
[__] thing to say
I think racism and all of these issues
do exist but I feel like I agree with
you guys and thank you guys because you
actually gave me a new way of thinking
that we don't have to use this as a
barrier because at the end of the day
what we think is what will manifest they
do they do exist like absolutely 100 do
exist but regardless of that you know
you still have to go out but you still
have to go out into the world and make
it work for you because that's the only
that's the only thing that we've got and
think about it this way like if racism
was such this big barrier that you guys
are exaggerating it to be wild we have
black billionaires like Jay-Z and Kanye
West well absolutely I mean if you think
about it if you think about any any
ethnicity any background any social
class you there are examples of people
who've gone on to become hugely hugely
successful so that's what you've got to
look at an incredibly disproportionately
not the guy who yes but no that's really
important point it's so in America
blacks are 13 of the population of
course most of the white people are
making the money it's a small population
it's just the amount of people but at
the same time there's more poor white
people in their going to be poor black
people just by statistical numbers
you know what I'm saying like of course
but the population of incarcerations
although it's only 13 of the black
population so how much of it is crime
though no but I'm saying how much of it
is crime regardless still but it's
higher than the white people right more
black people in the in prison by
percentage so would you say that would
you say that suppression are black
people's culture and and this is the
thing wait wait wait wait
can I say it sure right it is cultural
because this is the thing now with
racism because of culture and how things
happen back in the day people have just
been stuck in kind of like that limbo of
like okay what do we do now black people
are still trying to catch up with a lot
of things so that's why right now yeah
it is still a cultural thing and what we
can do is say the things that you were
saying is Empower yourself regardless of
what you look like because you are
letting the cultural context ruin your
prospects because you're letting that
make you be less when you're not and why
are you actually so surprised when he
said cultural aren't you surprised
aren't you a rapper so
what does that mean what genre of music
advocates for murder all the time hit
Paul hip-hop yeah so you're a rapper you
know the genre is is black dominated
they advocate for violence all the time
and you're gonna be like cultural you
know what my problem with it is actually
that I hate is when a young black man
goes and gets successful and obviously
because of the numbers in the
businessmen in the world he ends up
working white people and I call him an
Uncle Tom and I think that's [__]
I think no it is [__] I think they
only call you an Uncle Tom if you're
actually a certain way like speaking
correctly no no no I'm not trying to be
disrespectful I would never no I agree
with you but when I've seen people
called someone that Uncle Tom is in a
sense where you're just from what I've
seen is they will like when I watch NWA
is they
um they made all the black guys just get
on the floor for no reason just because
they were black and the black policeman
is just standing for it I would call
that an Uncle Tom because
which happened in real life by the way
it's a documentary so it's not fake
it happened in real life though that's
what I'm telling you ask you a question
you know a good like 40 to 50 of people
that have been incarcerated is because
of something that they didn't do how is
that culture for them do you think it's
40 or 50 I think it's a high percentage
for black people can I say something
very quickly culture can I say something
very quickly Pearl my sister listen let
me just can I just help you run this
conversation up because I know it can be
awkward especially with what happened
guys she is not racist she's a g racism
is not a hindrance it is a challenge but
you can overcome it and I'm so sorry
that I brought that into the
conversation because we're talking about
feminism feminism is destructive okay so
I'm so sorry Paul I didn't mean I don't
have to be sorry in your opinion a lot
of you guys who have this opinion about
feminism being destructive feminism is
the reason you're here you're here it
kind of is though because if we're being
honest the Equal Pay Act women even
getting into work because okay but who
started the whole movement for women to
even come out of the kitchen can I ask
you who's better
just recent Generations I know from what
I know my knowledge of feminism
um
in terms of the destructive feminism
that um came from Rockefeller I think
it's always been destructive I mean even
in the early days they planned
assassinations it's always been Freedom
at the expense of man
always even even like let's take the
vote like the vote was one of the first
things that we got right would you agree
that was a good thing that women got to
vote Yes okay but then women were not
equally drafted so if there's a war that
breaks out the men are the ones that are
have to have to go fight so that's why
women didn't want to vote because they
had to be drafted in order to vote
because if you're voting for in the U.S
it's the commander-in-chief who picks if
we go to war that's who you're voting
for so you have to have some skin in the
game so again women wanted the freedom
they want to say oh let's vote but they
didn't get the responsibility that comes
with it in the U.S selective Services up
to 200 000 per year but you know so so
if they don't enlist basically like if
if War breaks out and they don't um
sign up for the service basically they
get fined two hundred thousand dollars
but you know why women should still have
a say because the same way that men are
the ones that go to war that could get
killed is the same way that women are
then going to be left behind without a
father at home without a husband at home
so there's been there's
um effects of War on both sides that's
why you shouldn't just be men making
decisions we're all part of this Society
of democracy is about people we are all
people so that's why the vote makes
sense so yeah well I just I just think I
just think make it equal feminists want
equality then be equally drafted and go
on the front lines but then women say oh
no I don't want to do that okay well
then and it doesn't have to be about the
vote all of feminism is I want I want
special treatment because you always
hear the feminists talk about oh um
equal pay even though we get paid more
in a lot of Industries you never talk
about equal pay and sex work why are
women strippers paid more oh no let's go
March but nobody cares and this is why I
find feminism to be completely
contradicting because women will say
things like I want to have equal pay I
want to be making this amount of money
as men and then the minute they find man
that's making less money than them he's
a simp or he's soft
yeah it's very contradicting a lot of
the times you guys want equal pay you
guys want equal sexual Liberation
women that talk about equal pay or lazy
lazy it's usually they just I
I I cannot stand women that complain
about getting paid equal because I've
worked in so many industries that are
begging women to work there but their
hard jobs and women don't want to work
there I used to work in sales they
wanted female salesmen but then the
women would get the job and they would
quit it's just like what are you my
highest paid employee in all my
company's a woman
straight up and it is by a landslide
just just Christmas bonus alone was 30
grand on top of her salary and all of
her health benefits her gym membership
her car everything in her travel and the
vacations I send her on do you know what
can I say something that is really cute
about feminists I think that feminists
are just little girls that managed to do
something and they're so excited and
they just want people to say yay you
well done no but no I think that's what
she produces the most I know I know but
I'm talking about feminists because I
realize that sometimes I'm looking at
these girls and say oh yeah what we call
rights we want this we want that and
realistically no you just want the man
to be able to say to you oh you're a g
as well well done and it's actually
quite annoying because you don't need
that validation you know what I mean
because for me I don't that's you no I
know and that's why I'm saying I don't
like feminism but because most the
feminists that I've met are actually men
so I'm just a bit Latin yeah because
it's amazing strategy
so of course they are those are the Sims
the the ones that go and placate to
women and act like they want to be a
male feminists those are the simps they
hate guys like us they hate
a guy that lives by truth and just calls
it how it is and guess what you know
what that creates that creates respect
and you respect rings with a man and
woman love
you can't respect a man that you know is
full of [__] you can't what are you
talking you said this wanting validation
for men for being equal you just wanted
him to validate you for being able to
fix a car no uh listen
you keep talking about yourself do you
know why you get no do you know why
you're getting confused because you've
already immediately labeled me to be a
feminist I'm standing again it's not
about feminism you said that feminism is
wanting to get validation for men for
being equal let me clarify you you got
mad at him for not being able to fix a
car and we just all gave you put money
up to go fix the car students like you
let me explain why why you're actually
just looking for an argument because I'm
saying it's not an argument I'm just
trying to see the double standard what
you're saying feminists are actually a
bit confused and they're screaming for
so many things when in reality what
they're actually looking for is just yay
well done that's it because women cannot
go into things men go to work all day
every day and nobody thinks them exactly
and it's a thankless world listen and
that's what I'm saying having a movement
for it is quite pointless say you love
them to yourself and it's okay so I'm
actually against feminism because he
actually hinges me I'm get called that
all the time and it's so annoying
completely agree with everything else
out there I'm not because I've already
so why is you why did we all put up
money to go fix a car if you're not
exactly what you just described okay and
let me tell you why I am not a feminist
in that Essence because that's what I
want I want just somebody to say to me
oh by the way I'm not if I tell you that
I can fix the car oh yeah cool that's
good well done to you because I got
skills validation
she's exactly what she's describing
right now to you I'm explaining to you
the difference between what they say
they want what they actually really want
that's it because so what do you want
well I just want to be able to be
somewhere do something somebody said
yeah that's really good well done
[Laughter]
okay no I'm saying I'm belittling the
fact that feminists will stand there say
equal rights we want all of this when in
reality you're just a sweet little girl
that just wants to be like well done but
they are and yeah without all of those
movements you wouldn't be
without those women actually taking the
logic upon themselves you know using
that logic whether it was to do what
meant what was the example that you gave
when they were terrorists men have been
known terrorists for a very long time
we're talking back to the seven times
but what outcomes has that given for
women has that given us good outcomes
are we happier no or do we have more
children no
are we on are we on and we're on
antidepressants more than ever before
yes is this one because we're more
sexually promiscuous than ever before
we're in less relationships than ever
before more of us are childless over 30
than ever before what outcomes has
happened that it's that are good we can
point to individual things and say yes
we're on a podcast that's fun but in
society as as a whole
what what good has it done it got me to
meet you
[Laughter]
but also the other the other issue with
it is at what point you're talking about
yeah 50 years ago and that's how you've
got to this point and everything like
that there's a sort of but I believe
there is an even playing field now in in
certainly in the UK I think in the
United States as well Canada all these
anglosphere countries right I don't
believe that women are now held back in
any material way okay in terms of the
job market in terms of opportunities
being an entrepreneur et cetera et
cetera so what
no absolutely but but absolutely but at
what point do we say okay right now the
conversation is closed because now I
would even further and say that women
have more freedom than men
and that's where it becomes destructive
because it seems now the the the the
Power Balance has shifted more into the
feminine and then guys are actually
being disadvantaged now I do think
that's the that's the problem with
modern day feminism I think that
um everyone wants women empowerment and
I'm for women empowerment but we can't
pick and choose when we want feminism to
take place say for example like we want
a man to provide for us and care for us
and some people might want to be a
housewife but then also you want the the
other side of it and you want to take
control in the relationship or vice
versa yeah but she doesn't really want
that like it's not actually equal
because it's like who say for example
certain areas of work like a bin man
very few women want to be a bin man they
will say it's something I would say zero
yeah they would say it's a matter to
check the applications but then if you
want to look at feminism you guys want
equality but when it comes to certain
jobs you don't want to do them when it
comes to certain
certain instances you don't want to be
involved in them so it doesn't really I
think feminists pick and choose yeah it
benefits them no but I think something I
would say I think the issue here is you
guys are not trying to like not you guys
in general but just like women who are
like I'm not a feminist but everything
that you've actually being made like and
alive right now I mean and it's back to
my point of the 50 years ago 100 years
ago when your ancestors and your great
great grandmothers are sitting there in
the kitchen unable to do anything yeah
like feminism has benefited every woman
in today's society yeah I was about to
say I would suspect those women are
happier than these words
and how are they happier they're not
even here I would actually prefer to be
where women was in the 20s because the
pressure for me as a lady to work can be
very exhausting so when you sit here and
say that oh this is the reason why I'm
here today most women really don't most
women I'll be honest with you we do all
of this work boss chick stuff because of
the pressure that this feminist woman
has put on women to not be lazy and to
get up work so when you sit here and say
oh this is the reason why you guys are
here
most of us really don't want to be
saying
rights
just to correct something the first
female millionaire was um in the early
it was in 1900 so yeah the hair shop
later no but everyone says they couldn't
um Vote or they couldn't work until like
the 50s and 60s but before that there
was a female millionaire so dude there
someone did it yeah
that well to be honest making money is
not really that hard
you know this is the thing if you are
capable you can do anything whether
you're a man or woman the problem with
feminism I think is that it displaces
women a lot of the time because you're
trying to make us be something that
we're not like I work for myself I I do
I would say I am a boss in what I do but
I'm not a boss baby and I have to be
proved to my man that I'm this woman and
you I deserve certain things like all I
want is not because I'm a feminist just
because I'm a person that likes to be
told well then I just want if I'm with a
man to be like oh that's quite cool you
know Well Done For Trying that that's it
but I don't really get anything against
that I don't really get too many people
sometimes especially the people that
know me telling me things like oh your
woman you shouldn't do that so do you
want validation for men or not I just
want I don't it's not just for men I
want it from anybody even women that
will look at me and be like nah you
can't do that women do that to each
other so I don't want to be boxed in
because I'm a woman I just want to be
treated like normal just it's fine it
seems like your value system is
extremely external and exists in other
people's minds no not really this is in
terms of the contest of the conversation
because I think you can tell that I
don't actually need a much external
validation [__] I'm quite guys by myself
thank you but it seems like in some
Industries let's say in London we're in
London now right I mean if you look at
media industry if you look at
advertising
um uh certain types of like information
technology and stuff like that it's very
actually female based you know you've
got like say the advertising industry
you've got more female leaders in that
space than you have men so it seems to
me at some point we have to say right
well the balance has been addressed now
I think so it's getting there I think
women need to just kind of like Empower
themselves
and then it goes back what they were
saying before which is like okay man or
woman you've got to go out into the
world and you've got to bend it to your
will right you've got to make it you've
got to make your own narrative and not
and not fall back on these you know
things yes you summed that up and I say
I can see you've got good experience
talking to people and making them
understand the simple and Basics oh I
like that thank you for summarizing it
that way but you made a good point in
the sense that like when is that's then
the thing is with feminism is never
ending every week every month there's a
new issue it's so unnecessary that these
feminists one and it's just like when
are you guys going to be satisfied
that's my problem that's when it becomes
destructive because you can say that is
unnecessary to them because if they fall
away they fall away so I don't think
they're stupid they can have stupid
beliefs and feelings yeah but that
doesn't make it reality just because
they feel aware just because the girl
feels like she was discriminated because
of her gender doesn't mean that she was
and that's the big problem of this
generation is we don't know how to
differentiate between what we're feeling
and what's actually reality like I get
that's what they're feeling but but
right now I'm feeling like a dog am I a
dog no exactly so we have to learn to
differentiate between what we're feeling
and what's actually fat and we need to
do that by calling people stupid or
saying that they're acting like
[__] when they are like if someone
says you're vibrating with misogyny that
should be called stupid like
respectfully like that that was a stupid
thing to say it's an analogy it's a
figure of speech as well don't be so
mean what's the analogy the analogy is
basically saying you're coming to be
aggressive your energy is coming a bit
tense I even felt it so I I reworded
what she said tense and misogynistic no
I know but I rewarded it two very
different yeah but the accusation was
real it wasn't a figure speech
accusations
and that's my point like we need to call
that stupid when people say stupid
things and what do those accusations do
I mean you know sneako is a bit
different because I mean his his
Industries to get canceled but exactly
that's the best way in a way but it's
like for the average person that you you
label them that that could ruin their
entire career yeah it's a bit like it's
a bit like using the term creepy it and
then it's sort of like if a woman calls
a guy creepy just the fact that she said
it is it's believed because she she says
I felt that he was creepy so I was like
oh right okay so therefore he was creepy
because you you're saying you felt like
that but where's the where's the sort of
foundational truth of that statement
right and it's like saying vibrating
with misogyny okay well okay it was tens
but we're in a debate right so where
what's the misogynistic element of that
they were just having a debate because
why is he looking at her as an OP just
because she's a girl
if there was four guys sitting on the
couch and they were making the same
points
if we have different points of view we
are disagreeing but you don't know me so
don't go against me because we could
actually agree on things don't go
against me gender-based I don't like
that that's given us
that was the value I don't know if it
was off the gender I'm sorry
different opinions it has nothing to do
with Womanhood because your your
boundaries of like
um aggressive like
um tonality in the way you speak you
don't you know
which is a good thing I got canceled for
talking about covet in the election had
nothing to do with vibrating massages I
don't know you feel a little bit
aggressive I'm not gonna lie someone
said something along the lines of don't
go against me isn't this a debate like
for and against yeah but when you
immediately have to go against like come
on
by saying I'm a black immigrant I mean
look you guys are victims until somebody
calls you out it's it's just none of
this makes any sense you're going to go
and say that I'm a victim I'm black so I
have a hard time in life and then
somebody disagrees with you and then
you're even a victim we disagree and
that I'm aggressive and you're pointing
at me and interrupting me but I'm
aggressive
was aggressive there still you have been
the whole time but I'm aggressive I
don't say that you're vibrating with
Miss injury yeah exactly my whole point
of this argument my whole point is that
people now and especially people my age
I'm 24 we have such a victim mindset
that makes us feel like we can navigate
the world a certain way and that
everything is against us and we don't do
that because the world is against us
because it makes us feel better about
our life path and our decisions and
about our place in the world that is the
number one thing that will hold people
back I'm an immigrant I'm black you're a
misogynistic you're racist stop acting
like that's a victimization
I already explained to you why that is
my superpower I simply pointed out the
fact that it is an extra obstacle that
some people may not have but for me it's
a good thing it makes me fit saying that
you have an obstacle spicy and prettier
that's why I like having also saying
that you have enough believing that you
have an obstacle is exactly I know
because I felt it
just because you haven't lived my life
don't bloody so we encourage me home
tell him what I feel because that's why
a sneaker what you're trying to say is
that we should disregard our traumatic
experiences for that have but like you
know even if you were traumatized if you
had a terrible experience for good
things right if the KKK was burning
crosses and like what will hold you back
more is still thinking about that you're
traumatized is thinking that the world
is against you that will hold you back
even more than anything else that
anyone's going to tell you that any
industry will say that anything that I
believe how misogynistic and racist I am
you believing that you're traumatized
and navigating the world that way is
going to hold you back more than anybody
else and that's the number one thing I
would say for anybody here watching this
right now get rid of that mindset
because that was programming to you by
the news you're talking about mainstream
media showing this one afro dude they do
that so that we stay down it's not
because they actually care about racism
you think the news cares about this afro
guy no they care about programming
George Floyd you think that goes viral
because they care about George Floyd
well it's to get everybody riding and to
keep everybody confused and to keep
everybody outside no and to keep
everybody distracted a lot of people
leveled up because of that a lot of
addressing these issues actually is
quite empowering because you start to
work
I lived in Milwaukee during like the BLM
protest there were some shops that
didn't open back up of course like
they're
let me tell you something right things
like BLM things like wakanda what it is
why it's actually something that is is a
good thing to even talk about these
things and be gassed about the fact that
black people start to go to the
Forefront is because even though some
people may take as victimization there
are people that actually take it to be
an empowerment
exactly but to be awesome
how do you how do you know if the
outcome of something is good I know
basically I know because within my
business wait wait basically within my
business I see the change right okay
okay okay so you would say so you would
say it would be the results right yeah
the results of course so it's good the
government okay
okay
so if the results of those protests were
that some shops did not open back up and
the whole business was a scam how is
that a good result well it's the same
way that people go to war people do a
million things with good comes bad no
but I'm asking like what good came What
could what did BLM accomplish oh
[Music]
that McPlay George Floyd did they didn't
change the main factor which was white
corpse killing black people yeah
white clubs kill white people too so
what did BLM accomplish BLM in the UK
the governments are giving funding to
Black businesses a lot more they started
putting a lot of projects to Big up
black people and put them on so actually
it was a good thing for the UK I'm not
gonna lie a lot of people got really
good opportunities because of that
situation whatever then the nature of
the cops not have guns here no well
why was the UK even giving money to
Black businesses here when this had
nothing to do so you got some money like
yeah a lot of people make money how was
racism solved at all do you know if it's
not about racism being sold that's what
black lives but what it did it actually
gave extra leeway for people to
it gave you
any black you know this happen but look
we're gonna help you go go then take
advantage and you win and you grow it's
a good thing so when you talk about this
and you expose it every question I have
a question do you think throwing money
at a problem solves it of course not so
so like wait throw it at me it will
solve it are you a stripper can I also
make one point you said that um black
lives matter helped businesses and black
people build their brand or whatever but
I think we need to also question how
long is that gonna last because I feel
like this is just gonna last for like
the last two five years and after that
it's going to go back to just already
blown over yeah well it's it's going
starting to withdraw I think that's what
I've got let go even if it did solve
that problem in a sense where they're
supporting black businesses it didn't
solve the main matter
on TV like ZZ Mills is on channel four
now but I wasn't the minister is there
with another sister
the problem was white cops killing black
people the problem wasn't not having her
answer was they put a black person on TV
presentation you inspire other people to
want to because it doesn't solve the
problem no the problem is dizzy Mills is
on TV because she's talented to
insinuate it's because pretty racist
if you understand the industry you know
I ain't lying company
industry better than me
in London yes I built the biggest okay
the biggest podcast what do you know
about the London people them here not as
much as I do I've lived here hundreds in
the past you've met them do you know the
history you don't so you can't actually
tell me that you know more about the
book okay do you think ZZ Mills is on TV
because she's talented I'll tell you why
she's yesterday I think she's talented
but guess why she's on TV and why she
was given prime time because they want
to now make inclusivity and diversity
something nice
I have a question
on TV since the 80s or 70s but it also
sounds like you're admitting that
there's an advantage for being black and
it has nothing to do with skill set and
diversity and inclusion so where's the
mindset that black people are oppressed
no if you're getting a job for
representation this is not what I said I
said the 5
certain City
is making other people give
a team more opportunity
more inspiration the problem starts to
get so sounds like you're getting jobs
over your skin no but it doesn't matter
because the whole point is at least that
day when flying a planet matters well uh
these emails is talented that's why they
picked her they wouldn't just pick up
why can't it be that because
I feel like saying it's because she's
black takes away from her skill sets
let me tell you people
cancel me if you want but diversity
inclusivity is now something that every
corporate company is talking about
they're raving about it
it doesn't matter what you do with the
opportunities up to you but if you're
smart to take this opportunity because
right now you can make a lot are you
oppressed or not I'm not of course not
that's why I said me being black is
actually super it depends actually if
you was gonna run for a prime minister
that you would be famous prime minister
and he's brown isn't he yeah yeah no I
mean I don't agree with that I mean he
didn't get elected we do have a female
black vice president it's representation
I mean it is possible guys it is
possible and if you look at like the
percentages of white people versus white
people just actual percentages you know
you all do really really well you have a
lot of millionaires like we do I tell
you who I really admire who I really
admire is Lil Wayne he's one of my
favorite people because when he asked
about that he he doesn't live in that
way and he was so [__] successful not
living that way and just doing his thing
and I just I know I've said it three
four times I just want every young
person seeing this to hear it you can do
it bro you really can and don't live any
other way but you can that's it you can
do it and going back to the victim
mindset I would say that um
a lot of people wouldn't even go and
apply for that role to be president or
prime minister because they think like
that because they think okay I'm black
this I'm not gonna I don't have a chance
to go and do it and you actually put in
the effort and you were talented and you
over 30 years and doing everything he
had to do to get in the position to even
win because I mean the presidency is not
something you apply for right yeah it's
like over time you've come to know that
hey I got a shot at this thing and he
ran for it dude if Candace Owens around
tomorrow vote for her ass
straight up I would go for Candace Owens
ran for president tomorrow vote for her
I would vote for her that's such a I
would why
because I think she's intelligent I
think she knows her [__] and she's based
as [__] very bass yeah
I think sometimes before that's the
whole point of what I'm trying to say
sometimes and it's not because she's
Black by the way I know but zero because
of that you brought up denava you
brought up quotas before of course
beautiful uh quotas which is like
getting um a job because of your gender
or your race I brought them up for one
no but I'm saying you seemed like you
said it was a good thing you think it's
a good thing I think so don't you think
it's kind of a slap in the face because
it's saying that you can't do it
yourself no not really the reason why I
think quotas are I think but quote is a
racist and sexist but but it is but the
reason why I I'm I'm a bit like I'm kind
of going on the whole thing of use races
your superpower I don't really care
about why you're doing that as long as
I'm dead and I can make something good
out of it then great I'll go then I'll
turn it it's an opportunity so if I if
somebody now was saying to me okay
because your mixed race and you got
curly hair we want you to present this
show Primetime TV base because you've
got curly hair be like yeah no stress
like let me do it let's see how I'm
gonna do I'm gonna get famous I'm gonna
make money I can open another business I
can Empower through that opportunity
that came from a bad reason well I think
what what is good about what you're
sagas you're talking about seizing the
opportunity and you're talking about
using whatever whatever prospects come
along to get where you want to get to I
think there's a there's almost like a
Schism in this conversation isn't there
because I think what what these guys are
talking about and probably what I'm
talking about is more mindset based and
over here we're getting into the Weeds
about some of these social issues which
do exist 100 they do exist But
ultimately overall what we need to do we
need to transcend that because actually
I mean social class is a huge thing as
well right and actually you've sort of
paid lip service to that I mean so it's
not like Richie sunac he's the prime
minister of the United Kingdom but he
came from an incredibly privileged
background right so social class is a
big thing whether you're black or white
or Asian or whatever
um but people from very um
underprivileged social backgrounds can
also go on to become hugely successful
so what we all need to do is think sod
my background I don't my race by
ethnicity all of that stuff it's
irrelevant how am I going to go out
there and change the world today what am
I going to do what steps am I going to
take to make a dent in this universe
before I die in this short period of
time I got here Inferno more setting up
the generations that come behind you
yeah because for that man to be in a
position to be prime minister probably
his grandpa was a g his Grandpa's
Grandpa was a g and so it's a legacy
thing and creating a family that sticks
together and has certain family values
that can literally Propel into the
future normally it takes a couple
generations to create a Rockefeller type
family and so if if people start today
building that Legacy then it's a really
huge thing in fact I just got a text
yesterday from an NBA player who wants
to like talk business about something I
knew who he was because he was in the
league but his father and grandfather
own a large portion of real estate in
Baton Rouge and I knew who they were
just from the real estate world and so
when Kyle is his name is Collins Temple
he's been he's the class he's my
favorite NBA player not because he's the
best players because he's a [__]
Class Act gentleman you know what I'm
saying like yes I'll do whatever
whatever College wants to do Let's Do It
Let's do let's make money bro and my
suit guy's a black guy he knew him he
gave me my cell phone number the guy
that made this suit black guy right gave
me the contact the plug I don't care
because money is green and he and that
family the temple family is a is a great
example of a legacy family and that can
be made if young men see that it's a
possibility what about women and women
too yeah women too but the thing the
thing about women is this
you have to understand there's Primal
parts of us and most often like she was
saying earlier a woman would much rather
be with a strong man she looks up to and
be inside the frame of the family and do
the maternal things the things that
matter the things that the world cannot
live without a mother I think being a
mother is one of the strongest most
impressive hard jobs in on the planet
that baby will not sleep you can't get
any sleep you've been pregnant your
body's torn up and then you still have
to nurture that baby and not get upset
with it not shake it not you know it's
maddening right like list not belittle
that job one of the most important jobs
on the planet because you're molding the
Next Generation that might be that
Legacy holder for your race or or your
family or whomever
so I I think that it's really really
really important that we put mothers on
a pedestal more than we put rappers and
I don't mean that to disrespect you I
just mean it because it's what's
important for the children and the thing
is that feminism comes in and says that
motherhood isn't enough and that's
[__] is that Evolution we were
talking about oh you get to work you get
to do this well we got to be mothers I
mean my grandma she had uh she had nine
kids and she said her one regret in life
is not having 12.
it wasn't being a rapper yeah
yeah it wasn't dropping 16 bars in Sway
and I think and I think that's one of
the worst things about feminism is
because if I was to speak out now and
say that I just want to be a
stay-at-home wife with six kids people
would look at me I'd call you a hero
she's lazy but I think that's like the
best part of a woman's life is having
kids and raising them is a privilege you
want to hear what's going to call you
lazy though huh you know who's going to
belittle that
this is why women need to be very
careful who they keep around because a
lot of time you're in competition with
each other and misery loves company
whenever a woman now on social media
when they see like a famous woman in a
happy relationship you see them all the
time trying to bring them down trying to
catch them cheating they want to be at
the same level because it's jealousy
misery loves company and so a lot of the
friendships that women have they aren't
productive whatsoever a lot of them are
feeding garbage when you get into
breakup when you have problems with your
boyfriend and you go talk to your
girlfriends what do they say leave him
leave him right now let's go to the club
they don't actually promote anything
positive they just want to bring you
back down to degeneracy watch out she
might text him I had a friend that told
me to leave him but was texting him yep
those are female friends and that's
that's what's really destructive about
feminism is that you talk about female
empowerment and then you guys bring each
other down more than men do that's
actually the real misogyny is you trying
to to destroy each other's lives and
ruin each other's relationships for
jealousy we're not the massages because
I'm speaking aggressive it's misogynist
to not want a woman to be a mother which
is the happiest State a woman could ever
be in well how can you say that what did
I say that's wrong what is wrong about
what I said just say what you just said
I'm not repeating it for you like see
you right now perfect example you didn't
even hear what I said it's the way I
said it and now you're upset you don't
even know why you're mad I know what you
said hear yourself speak okay okay what
did he say that was wrong it's how I
said it
what did he say that was wrong what
about all the barren women what about
women that can't have kids
yeah but those are outliers wait have
you ever have you ever spoken to a woman
that can't have kids that's Baron yes
they're usually miserable they're not
happy with that and if you talk to you
know what percentage of women that don't
have kids are happy with it less than 20
percent
the majority of women that don't have
kids are not happy so he's right what
did he say that was wrong that's perfect
example of feelings over facts she
pulled the Greta Thunderbird what did he
say that was incorrect how did he exists
when I say that was wrong yeah what did
he say you just saw you're just it's
just like you're throwing out these
facts like and you think a woman's sole
purpose is to be a Marvel okay there's
nothing more there's nothing more okay
whilst I do believe there is nothing
more important than not actually I don't
believe that I don't believe that
there's there's more to women in society
what's more important than having
children
name name five things being healthy no
no no I'm not asking you Janella what's
name five things
um
being healthy is a pre-worker
your actual career your dreams from a
little girl yeah we from from a child
all girls we all have a dream like
whatever the truth it's Charming usually
not all of us have the biggest challenge
being stable okay okay okay so wait wait
wait I just want to talk to you so so
your career what else what else is more
important your mental stability your
health
your um contribution to society outside
of motherhood so so you're 65. okay by
yourself okay your career is more
important yeah I'm a cat mom and I've
got a great career I've made I've made
I've left I've made my marking as well
just like my mom has like just like
because if a man doesn't have kids at 65
the society look at him in any way I
agree that mental stability is important
but for me if I hit let's say 30 and I
have no kids my mental stability will be
very low I'll be depressed and even
though I want to be this I want to be
that I want to have a career so badly if
I don't have kids like I wouldn't know
what to do you're completely right let
me just tell you something right now
like you said you're going to be a cat
mom no I'm saying I'm not saying I'm
going to be I'm saying there's women
like that is that what you're on the
road and not only that women sense
lesbians is that what you want genuinely
I'm not trying to be aggressive do you
want to be a cat mom
you talk about your contribution to
society it's dropping a rap song having
an Instagram like what your your tits
are out and then having some cats is
that what you want what do you think
women do is that I haven't seen your
Instagram motherhood that's probably
what that's the only value you see in a
woman the only thing that I'm asking you
no but I'm saying the only thing the
only value that a woman has in your eyes
is motherhood so everything that's the
most important for every woman you get
with as long as she has kids she's
valuable no but is that what you're
trying to say though the highest
contribution to society a woman has his
mother so what's the what's the highest
contribution that man has
invent build and maintain Society can I
just challenge you quickly didn't you
say that there would be none of this
without women having children
but I'm what I'm trying to say is I
don't like the fact that there's a lot
of men who have this mentality towards
women I don't see your value as a woman
outside of Let Me Marry You Let Me breed
you like a [__] like a [__] cow and
then you know like you're gonna stay
there I'm gonna do what I need to to do
and all your whole purpose in your whole
existence is to do nothing but have my
kids
why is that a bad thing it's not like
that that's what I look at look at
that's what my grandma did she had nine
kids and now she has over 50 grandkids
and I feel like you're you're making it
seem more terrible
motherhood to being a cow you just
compared motherhood to breeding being
bred like a cat comparing like the
attitude that I heard what you said why
are you trying to fix it because you're
misinterpreting what she said I heard
something different she's not saying
that she's saying the attitude that
people have to say that women should
just be mothers and your motherhood is
the most important no wait wait wait
that's wait yeah yeah well she's trying
to really say is that attitude that you
say that that's what women are for what
they are about makes it look like we're
just like little what do you call the
cows the
uh
over here hold on you're starting to
realize the mindset that a lot of these
women have they're comparing motherhood
to being bred like a cow is just very
bad because I feel like with you and I'm
not trying to attack you but I just feel
like you're trying to make it seem more
dark than what it actually is a lot of
men yes they're very privileged by the
fact that they've picked the woman and
they want to have children with them but
it's not just centered around them maybe
they just love their company it's not
maybe they just love their softness
you're just making it seem like softness
men just come and just like let me have
your children that's like five percent
it's not in the vast majority cases it's
not that the men just look at the woman
as this kind of breeding animal he's
like I'm gonna improve
can you explain what you were talking
about what are you talking about then if
you're not talking about that no I don't
think they're talking about that because
they haven't made it clear you just said
that motherhood's the most important
thing so for you your sole purpose is to
get with a woman and have a kid with her
I want to clarify career is more
important than motherhood yes or no
so in in a society career is more
important than motherhood yes or no yes
or no
the way you're arguing you're just
arguing with everything but you know
you're not even making a clear Point get
your point if your point is if your
point is that career is more important
than motherhood say it it depends no but
not it depends in the world because
she's like there's everyone comes from a
different place saying what you said to
educate children
a very very difficult background
what are you okay what I'm saying is
okay we're dealing with the facts of the
West right now in it like this is where
we're at not in Africa not in do you get
it like other countries where they have
these values that oh yeah um and some
men still have that mentality that's a
woman so that woman's not it's like
what yeah what results does that does
that lead to
are women happier in the west I think so
I don't think so
what's okay
let me just think this through with you
okay how would we measure if women are
happier in the west or in other
countries the rate of women on what
antidepressants because you would agree
depressed women take drugs to not be
depressed
right okay so if the women in the west
are on antidepressants higher that means
their results are not good if we're more
obese than other countries our results
are not good so yeah we're more
successful
not in terms of happiness you see your
basic success monetarily success is
about enjoyment of life it's not about
wrestling I thought y'all weren't paid
equally what I thought you weren't paid
equally
that's not what she said financially
successful
no she means more financially
independent success is not about how
much money because Financial
Independence is important for example
I'll give you information my average
woman makes like 25 000 a year so
they're not that successful
can I ask you a question that's poverty
okay comparative compared to the
countries
probably would have a better lifestyle
because they live off of their family's
income we have our husbands you know
sister can I say something yeah it's
important for women to have Financial
stability because you can't always rely
on men to be there because it's not just
because men are trashy men are not
reliable everybody dies which means that
you as a woman need to also be able to
count on a way to start to stabilize
yourself because if you do have children
you also need to be able to provide for
the children so things go wrong for
example so why that's why certain things
like Financial Independence and having a
career can't be important for women and
I know this because I speak like about
my mom from experience if she didn't go
to work and she was a a housewife if she
didn't go to work we would have been
suffering we should have to go jump in
bed with somebody else to provide for
her which she didn't do so she went to
work so it's good thing it's a good
thing for me to go and work and have a
career I don't think they I don't think
what we're trying to say that women is
work women working is a bad thing what
we're trying to say is women putting
work over family is a bad thing because
if you go back to what Paul said the
results have been bad also as well a lot
of work is not really what it's cracked
up to be I mean it seems like women of
work really really hard and fought
really hard to be able to go and work in
cubicles for you know eight hours a day
which is pretty [__] you know let's
let's face it not every most people
aren't going to become cardi B most
people aren't going to become like a
world famous rapper or you know like uh
a super influencer right most jobs are
not very good so why is there this why
is this importance put on to that when
actually most people are trying to get
out of work because it's you know out of
normal jobs because they're so terrible
it's because feminism made these women
think that being a mother is a bad thing
that they're oppressed they're the
compared to cows to being bred they're
not they don't see any value in being a
mother they compare themselves to men
all the time they want to go fix cars
like we do they want to go rap like we
do they want to make money scars only
women women aren't as good at it well if
I get stuck in them
wait wait look at look at this time wait
the the top 10 rappers of all time are
they men or women
there's a woman and there's a woman or
the majority stop come on are the
majority men or women
no definitely okay so women aren't as
good at it well that doesn't mean that
they're not as good at it
doesn't mean
that's exactly it's not not do you know
why because that's the same thing as
saying women have only just started
going into science because it's more
encouraged but because there's more men
Engineers they're all better than women
no women can't be good at it but they're
just still trying to go into things
because we are still catching up with
something that's been definite for very
long time because you're no because
you're we're picking in like they're
trying to push women into Industries
we're not naturally good at listeners
wait dinova it's like it's like we're
trying to make women into men and we're
not men no rapping is not for men
because rapping is odd women if women
wanted to do it and we're good at it
they would do it men men as rappers sell
more because whatever it is that they're
rapping about as well is more like it
helps men feel empowered feel this
there's a there's a certain Advantage
for men within that industry that's just
can I ask you a question why aren't men
like top of the what's the word top of
the list when it comes to like the
beauty influence they are though no
they're not yeah
who dominates the modeling industry in
men or women why does Gisele make more
than Tom Brady
exactly clearly because they're better
at it women are better at makeup men are
better at other things we need to stop
acting like we can lose
sometimes there's exceptions sometimes
there's an exceptions I know there's a
male YouTuber who can probably do more
makeup than me but if we're talking on a
general senses because women
because women please the visuals because
we're good at that it's true also but we
also know she asked why I said because
but I'm not arguing I'm agreeing but
yeah but the same way we can admit women
are better at this and women are better
at visuals and so why are we so afraid
to admit that men are better than other
things than we are exactly for example I
would not want to have a man running a
nursery school because I wouldn't want
to leave my small child with a man I'd
rather leave it but then why but then
why do you argue so hard
wait wait that manner that manner better
rappers than women because the results
show it no because there's more men
rappers and they do better at it's like
I'm talking to a kid right now you're
very childish I understand why you think
she's good TV because you just talk
you're just talking like what are you
talking about okay I'll tell you why for
example rapping what is rapping rapping
is Right lyrics is it like a Poe it's
poetry essentially right okay the only
difference between poetry and rapping is
because when you rap you flow on a beat
cool so that has nothing to do with you
being a man or woman now when it comes
to taking care of children and babies
for example then there I'm going to say
yeah it is about being a man and a woman
so there's certain things where the rule
does not apply and there are certain
things that the rule definitely apply so
I am not stupid sir I'm not calling you
stupid but just because you're speaking
loud it doesn't mean that you're making
I can't hear myself too well so
obviously I have to project my voice
listen a little bit because you're not
making a good point just because you're
speaking up okay why did I not make a
good point you're not having any stance
you say you're not a feminist but you're
saying that women should be scientists
too we can rap the same but also I'm not
there because I'm not feminist I just
see people have skills you've been
talking the most out of anyone on this
panel and you have no specific record my
point of view
you guys guys just want to argue about
black and white when there's great
points in the middle the same way that
sometimes the rule applies where men are
better or something than women and
sometimes it doesn't happen
you've been on too many shows to not
know that we are talking about in
general like I I've told you this so and
I've been on too many shows to know that
I see it's not my point so that I don't
know
you can't you can't you can you can say
your point but that doesn't mean you're
right no but this looks better so there
you go it's not about for everybody
watching it's not about making a clear
point it's just this is her time she's
on camera you like talking about
empowerment it's about say calling
[__] on black and white you like
hearing your own voice I love my voice
and I like looking at myself this is
narcissism you have no point of view
you're just here to talk just agree with
you because you're taking saying things
like I think all right I'm gonna I wanna
I wanna hear from you because I I don't
think we have also I'm just here again
heated a little bit I just feel like
everything so feminism it's just women
demonizing everything that women are
good at so being able to give birth
reproduction is beautiful
it is a beautiful thing
why are we demonizing it why are we
relating ourselves to cows yeah who said
that who was it that said that right
negative and I hate to bring religion
into it but as a Christian I can only
speak on what I know in the Bible like
the main focus for women is to reproduce
so for you to try and make it seem like
it's a bad thing is literally ludicrous
to me we're on this planet and this is
why I say that there's nothing else to
it forget Society forget everything else
we are literally here to make children
right and this is why I said feminism is
demonicles
give birth to a child actually I can be
a mother but I also I am an educator I'm
here to help you get in the wrong way
we're not saying that we're just I'm not
here to just give birth
guys one at a time wait wait thank you
I'm Gonna Let You Go go ahead that's not
what we're saying because when she asked
for a fun fact I said first my career
I'm well not here I'm not saying that
I'm here to just become a mother to just
give kids but we are saying the main he
said the most important thing is
motherhood and you guys are trying to
take away from the fact of the matter
the fact of the matter is that the most
important thing for a woman is to be a
mother you can want to create you can
want to be rich mental health all of
that that's all nice and fun but the
main factor of life is the most
important thing is what is being a
mother and you guys are just trying to
argue with the sake of arguing because
what you guys are saying you're just
both contradicting yourself and you're
both bumping heads which makes zero
sense more meaningful ultimately in life
terms is it having a child is it having
a family is it having that those
connections with other human beings you
know in this brief period on this planet
or is it going to work in a cubicle for
eight hours that's the most important
thing for men then if women is giving
birth voice for you guys creation
okay that's a good one in every way yeah
creating everything inventing building
maintaining Society creating children
and then protecting and providing for
that family including a very good mother
and wife have been doing a good job at
that League no I don't but I also think
that it's in a lot of ways since the
women control the sex and the men
control the relationships the abundance
of sex and and the promiscuity and the
agenda that we're currently going
through I think it's making both sides
very sad
right so it doesn't have to be a gray
area that's what you're saying to
dismiss the argument the point is like
men have a specific role and women have
a specific role that's a black and white
that I think we should agree on
definitely and we can also agree that
men and women are equal just in
completely different roles
that's all the world doesn't go without
mothers particularly mothers they're
they're going to be the foundational
base of every human that comes into this
world not just after the fact but while
she's holding the baby how she treats
her body while that baby's there the
words that are coming out of her mouth
and that baby can hear you while she's
in there everything about that situation
in the atmosphere that the mother
creates is going to have a lot to do
with the mental health of that child boy
or girl it's the most important job in
the world and then at some point when
it's a little boy I'm very big on
handing that little boy off to the
father
and the father gets to take care of that
family he gets to be a man he gets to be
the hero for that situation that's
what's broken about everything we're
talking about
you know in those situations may I ask
may I ask so obviously that's really
important but how do we then
to make it a little bit more rounded and
a bit more like wholesome what advice do
you give to the women in terms of what
do they have to build for themselves to
prepare for a potentially eventuality or
the occurrence of your husband passing
away early maybe you've got two kids for
him one is three one is one what do you
tell a woman that has just completely
given herself to being a housewife and
doesn't actually have skills or the
abilities or knowledge to strive in the
world
because she just wanted to be a
housewife and then what does that what
happens to her I mean so there's a bunch
of technical ways like life insurance
but there's also the man you pick you
know women a lot of their success in
life is picking the right horse hate to
say you better pick a good one you know
people get shot sometimes if they get
run over people get shot I doubt that
I'm gonna get shot in life I'm not gonna
be in that situation no I'm just saying
in general to pick a man that's not
gonna get [__] shot you understand
what I'm saying like it's not about him
going off the war he shouldn't have been
the damn neighborhood okay right he
should have been doing the [__] he was
doing he shouldn't have been [__]
with the people he's [__] with so a
woman one of the most important things
she can do in her life is pick the right
partner of course you know you have to
choose yeah and and look and you have a
lot of risk in that especially nowadays
because you get to that one percent man
you pick him and now you're dealing with
problem skewity and all those other
things right and that's a whole
different subject but what I'm saying is
is if a woman can find a man that is
strong and she can look up to and she
can trust and there's a real
relationship there she has no problem
getting inside of her frame and then
inside of his frame and then all of a
sudden there's not a thought about you
know whether or not you know there's
feminism in the house it's more like I
trust this man fully and guess what
makes him motivated more than anything
in the world to take care of them is
that trust that she puts in him yeah
because he takes it seriously and he
becomes a hero in life and he wants
nothing more than to create a life for
that woman and those kids that would
have been one-tenth of what it had been
if he would not have come into that life
and that's what motivates men it truly
truly is and if you have a good woman
that can accept that and accept you
being the leader you will kill for her
yeah and so that woman will have nothing
to worry about because he'll do his duty
as a man and a real man would take care
of his family protect provide and a
woman that supports him is nothing I
promise you the happiest women in the
world yeah so oh go on sorry can I it's
okay if I can ask them a question would
you guys want your wives I don't know if
you guys are married but would you guys
want your wives to work
how do we know [__] no no why not well
listen because why I'd rather them raise
the kids like why I'm gonna provide I'm
gonna be the one bringing the bread home
I don't want her to because I don't want
to have to work out a necessity that's a
lot of pressure to put on men that
aren't able to earn salaries where they
can feel pressure makes diamonds yeah
and that's not hey look that's Darwinism
that's the best thing for the species do
you guys ever think that maybe there
might be like she was speaking about
that five percent five percent chance
that you might get run over a call you
might get cancer or something
she wants to pick a guy who who is gonna
have to wear with also if that situation
if that eventuality did occur she would
be looked after even in the uh in the
point of History you should live your
life out of fear like what if the worst
case scenario happens and I think a lot
of times as women we kind of go into
situations out of fear instead of
thinking about like what good could
happen is it feels it being realistic I
mean what what percent of husbands like
die young
what what percent is is it a high
percentage even even if you guys have a
college degree your chance of getting
divorced is 10 percent
you should be more scared of that than
your husband dying I'll say another
thing too you know how they say a lot of
men are bombs and a lot of men are [__]
if you only if there was a society where
only the men that truly produce and
could truly take care of a family could
reproduce you would watch men's
production Skyrocket through the roof
because I hate to say it men get up out
of bed every morning whether a brick
later an inventor or they're trying to
make a rocket ship to the Moon it is in
pursuit of women
thank you that is the driving force of
society but it's just a yin and yang
it's just a fact of the world so a lot
of women have babies with [__] men
so
you got to pick them like make sure your
picker's not broken and then be in a
position and create a scenario and an
error about yourself that tells the high
quality men that I am a quality woman
and I am worthy of you taking care of me
fully and if you want to work work but
it's not it shouldn't be because you
have to work that's that's my problem
with a woman working is that she gets
forced into working because the man's
not doing what he committed to in the
beginning which is protecting and
providing if she gets bored I would let
her open up a little dumb store that
sells like yeah little trinkets or hair
stuff that you know woman exactly is
fine I do think that just because the
man is the provider it doesn't mean the
woman has to have zero skill and what
you just said you said I'll let her that
was I think that's the wrong thing to
say you're led to have a hair business
you know what though when a woman when a
woman is like crazy in love and there's
true genuine desire what she really
wants to do is help build the kingdom I
have a question for you because you you
said you're a Christian right you don't
believe in submitting to your husband no
of course but he's saying so so yes you
would have to like you don't believe in
submitting to your husband's Authority
50 50.
my wife a lot of fake Christians
no there's a lot of fake Christians in
the church because you guys don't
believe in male Authority no no no no
because you guys need to understand what
being a Christian means just because I
said I'm a Christian doesn't mean I
follow the Bible
okay
so this is why Christianity's family
yeah so so you're at pick and choose
Christian Christian you're a I'm a
Christian when it benefits me no that's
not what I'm saying there's something no
can I also say something and I think
this is why divorce rates are
skyrocketing because people don't
understand what the true meaning of
marriage is if you actually read your
Bible you would understand that marriage
is a union between two people so two
people could become one
meaning once you're married once you
make a decision you have to run it with
your partner and your partner has to
kindness you guys are talking about
somebody dying you guys are talking
about oh what if the husband dies but
what's far more likely to happen
what's far more likely to happen is that
the woman divorces him because we know
that what is it 70 of divorces are are
started by women right 80 sorry so um
that's that is the eventuality
it's because women get bored because the
butterflies go and then they think I saw
this I'll go off and you know hold on
sneaker I've got a question for you I'm
not being funny Would you be with a
woman who earns more than you that would
never happen exactly this is but that's
the reality of certain situations
relationships it's not about insecurity
those relationships always fail what is
it according to which that always
happens the woman needs to look up to
her her man always yeah
it's female nature if you're you're not
a female so you wouldn't know okay I
understand female I understand female
nature better than you I have to be
successful no you don't I don't know
what makes you qualified to speak so
much ongoing exactly do you have
something okay this is how female it's
not don't it's not therapy
how closely you are with females let him
finish this point so what is your
question because now you're you're
vibrating with Miss injury I'm sorry
to get rid of this TV so she could stop
looking at herself I don't know she nice
I like my outfit like my hair look I'm
shining I've got red I think I think the
reality is a lot of men wouldn't be with
a lot of men are always talking a
certain way about a woman because she's
not a high earner and because it it went
like because she's not a high earner
she's a lot of women put themselves in
positions with certain mindsets that
they want a man who is above them can
you name one relationship where the
woman is in charge and it works I can't
name every love relationship where a man
is in charge and it works every single
one that worked every single successful
relationship ever the man is in charge
but the husband that's not crazy but and
your opinion this is every successful
relationship this is how we are alive as
the man is taking lead he's in charge of
the household and then she's running it
this is how it works it's common
knowledge you know I'll be honest it's
very simple very very very
woman would want to be with a man that's
earning less than them
because I'd feel like I'd have to wear
the pants in the relationship exactly
what happens when Financial situations
occur I'm going to have to take the
heavy load of that because I am the
breadwinner of the family yeah exactly
and what you said it's not just about
who pays for stuff I mean that's
important but it's also about respect
and as I think it was Justin said before
I mean if respect ultimately you can't
have love without respect and if she
doesn't respect him she's not gonna love
him really yeah women working is
actually a Madness for men now exactly
because men now need to work a lot more
because women can get the same type of
paying jobs as men so most men that are
working an average job now they need to
work 10 times harder to be able to get a
girl that works but that's why they have
this mentality of suppress a woman and
feel like okay if suppress these women
and make them think their only purpose
is be smaller so I can look bigger I
don't think it's about suppressing women
though I think it's the mentality though
it's I think oh women are like I think
you want to be
he's having a normal conversation with
you and you called him a misogynist or
you said he is vibrating
I'm all going to take it back you don't
need to of course because you're going
to die on your Hill it's very it's very
obvious absolutely yeah
and I'm not the only person who feels
you have a very well you need to be
right does anyone else vibrate with
misogyny right now
[Music]
said you
'll feel the value
Vibe but you are and I'm happy to be the
only one you've got to be more specific
though you can't you can't throw an
accusation at somebody it's it's like I
know this isn't a court of law but you
can't just throw an accusation about
against somebody and not substantiating
other than by saying well this is what I
feel he's moving like girls are stupid
that's why no you just be friends
it's because it's because you're acting
stupid I'm not acting stupid yeah I mean
you've been saying nothing half the show
you talk a lot without anything when I
post this content guys you see who the
substance that I've got is just because
we're in the middle of the heat people
don't get what I'm trying you're gonna
edit it yeah
an Editor to make sense you don't make
sense that was wrong you just didn't say
anything simply you know you have no
point of view on anything because I'm
trying to fish all the information from
you my point of view is very simple I
don't have to agree I'm trying to fish
out the information so is this an
interrogation or a conversation it's a
podcast it's fun but what I do is
exactly the way you keep looking at the
TV and talking here you're here for the
entertainment value but you're not
really here to get anywhere let me tell
you so you know why I'm a teacher yeah
and what I do is when people say certain
things I say things home to school you
understand to make you understand that
what you're saying doesn't quite make a
lot of sense go deeper than that because
when you go deeper your arguments
actually don't stand you do act like
girls as cheap and you've tried to catch
me out a million times yeah I already
know it's funny
though you're never gonna know about the
females
you can't you can't look stupid if you
don't say something stupid I don't say
anything can I say something I don't
think he's making women look stupid I
think he's making you look stupid
that's how he feels that's how he feels
but he's he says that he's in order to
be successful he studied the female
nature so females again in my opinion
from how you've worded it I feel like
you are viewing women as
so you know like
I don't want to say beneath that's why
I'm using misogyny like because you have
this mentality like and it's stuck there
and that's what misogynistic meant
that's how they view women that's how
they view the world and yeah I don't
know but hold on whereas in your mind
that might you might feel like that's
gonna get you far because it's a man's
world what I'm in my opinion I don't
think it is I don't think it's a man's
world can you define misogyny for me I'm
not going to do that I'm sorry you're
throwing out this word you don't even
know what it means no I don't need to
explain anything to you it's not an
explanation well I don't need to Define
anything to you I said what I said and I
said your environment it's not what it
means to me there's a clear definition
because obviously maybe we've got the
wrong definition misogyny is hatred of
women yes okay now you know what it
means
I've been knowing what it means and I
feel like you have some of that embedded
in you like maybe subconsciously but
seriously you have a bit of it babe that
because that because I said yeah
fun just for fun out of all the women
here who thinks Nico's misogynistic
raise your hand I think he's like he's
got he's like on the Spectrum
but the majority of us here we're not
yeah obviously only one person put that
handle funny how the two feminists the
two feminists raise their hands well
she's not a feminine feminist she's not
feminist you just make no sense
because I don't can I say something
about myself as a or b I just am what I
know different experiences because you
don't label yourself as aob but you said
you're not a feminist yes you've
contradicted yourself this whole how
because I don't live with myself as a
feminist I just say no it's because you
talk out of both sides of your mouth um
you make circles and you talk out of
both sides of your mouth of course I
feel like the whole life I'm not
feminine I'm proud of that is that like
are you happy about that that means that
is fun makes it what should you say for
the concert
appear to argue I'm here to make you
understand that what you say in the way
you so forth please say that this is
what it is no it's not
wounded masculine energy but if he was
to say it softly he will be sassy no I
can feel it still you know I agree but
if it was to say it softly he will be
softer you'll be sassy listen what do
you guys want I don't want everybody
wants to say it softly and less firmly
you guys now called himself and Sassy
Sweet I already had a conversation with
him so I'm a misogynist or my sweet your
problem problem is and when you put
yourself with the camera yeah the reason
why this is going on is because you come
with just between YouTube no I I but I
feel it I agree with her and I'm not
actually being with him did you feel the
vibrations as well no no personally from
high raised your hand from how you speak
right and from how you the words you
choose saying how you say so do you
think I'm misogynist yes or no
can you can you have a point of view on
anything you're missing you've got yeah
you've got that ideology a little bit
I'm sure I don't think you have a hatred
towards women I think you're just
stating the facts in modern day Society
yeah it's not it's not necessarily it's
not necessarily like a particular view
but it's actually what is going on in
today's world that's like factual I
think feminists hate women yeah they do
they do they do she was sitting on
motherhood more than I ever did I said
that was the highest form of a woman's
life is to raise kids and she compared
it to cows like that's that's more
misogynistic than anything I could have
said imagine if I said that
you want to have kids you're a cow
you're just gonna breed kids
you know it's crazy that's hating women
you know it's crazy the reaction
channels will pull that clip and then
say that you said it
but we're here for a conversation not to
get edited yeah going back to you guys's
Point why because I'm only 23 so I'm
kind of torn between whether I would
want to continue working after I have
kids from your opinion like why would
you feel like women working is something
that they shouldn't do it's not that you
should or shouldn't it's just ideally no
if you're with the right man then you
wouldn't have to work if you want to you
can but I would rather that you raise
the kids yeah who's who's gonna be
watching the kids when you're at work
some babysitter and so then you have a
stranger influencing your kid more than
you are and you have to look at it as a
place of trust and love he picked you he
he trusts you and picked you over every
woman in the world put his children in
you and instilled that trust in you to
take care of them while he's away making
sure the family is taken care of is
there a more important duty I just
listen
I think that women in the workplace I
think women kill it in fact my
Construction Company all of my managers
outside the managers that are in the
field are women and they're very good at
they're very organized I call them my
Trojan horses because they get more in a
negotiation than a man could because
it's not a dick measuring thing right
but at the same time a lot of those
women are past the years of being a
mother and their kids are grown and
they're in their 50s and their
professional business women but I
suspect that any woman that gets a high
level guy who chooses her and chooses to
trust
her with one of the most important
things in this world his children
that should be an honor past any other
job that I can think of for a woman now
does that mean that a woman can't go out
there and make money and have an impact
on the world outside to be a mother no
it doesn't women can just buying largely
on the macro what a beautiful job to
have
yeah it's just a warning side I'm not
trying to be misogynistic but I'm
telling you like having cats and rapping
is not where you're going to find your
higher purpose and it's not going to
give you the satisfaction of life that
you could find if you submitted to a man
and it's submitting it doesn't have to
be suppressing it's not misogynistic to
submit to your husband that's a woman's
happiest state is submitting to a man
that she loves 100 woman he's 100 right
you know you know what I believe if if
more women would take that role there'd
be less women on antidepressants but
there are a lot of women here who are
willing to take that role so what is
your point there are a lot of women who
share this mentality you're not
different than them no I am
I've made that clear I'm not gonna lie
you're not like other women no I'm not I
don't want what other women or
traditional women or women that are that
what every woman wants I have a
different dream I have a different
purpose
no did I say that and I'm asking what is
your dream no I'm sorry that I don't
dream too what is your dreams
I'm not I'm a rapper that's as far as it
goes and you know okay let's say you
became the world's biggest rapper yeah
and you took that to the to the extreme
is is that more impactful on the world
at 65 than having five kids
so so because once when you're gone
who cares your career is gone
what do you what do you have to show for
it in the world my music
well stream it love it you know
um
so that's that's better than a child
no no one said that but I'm just saying
but you're not you're not saying
anything
what I'm saying is
back to what this guy said I could I
just don't like them and I keep saying
it because I can see it like the way so
you skip the dream part I'm misogynistic
whoa
no you're not you're not you're you are
misogynistic but you're not going to
admit it that's the thing like you don't
think I hate women you don't think but
yes I do some of the women that you
probably met okay actually you know I
figured it out I figured it out I don't
hate women at all you said that you're
not like other women
I don't like that I don't like women who
think that they're different who want to
be men who want to be rappers who want
to be I have no problem with women I
have a problem with women that don't
even can't Define misogyny but calling
me misogynistic that prefer rapping over
having children
right now I literally asked you what did
I just ask you I said what um
do you hate women and you said oh I
don't hate women but I hate women that
fix so yeah I wouldn't even really
consider that a woman I don't I don't
really find you very feminine you're not
you're not you're not and that's sad
that's okay I don't find you masculine
so the feeling is mutual my point but
you have the mentality on of these
social media men like the men on social
media who have so much to say internet
Warriors let they've got so much to say
about what a woman should do how a woman
should dress how I should look you're
not feminine like oh like yeah there are
women that are not feminine women like
this is the real world yeah
and they die alone
they don't get paid women outlive men
anyways and why would you want it's not
a competition I'm not saying it is but
statistically women outlive men so
what's your plan my point is that it's
not it's not misogyny you didn't have it
consciously like you have misogyny you
have misogynistic views yes it's not
anything you do you I you know for free
and that's coming from a woman okay
you're not very well but the majority of
the women's in the room said he wasn't
misogynist and the majority of the women
in this room come from religious
backgrounds etc etc so they have a
certain things
why did it come from a religious
background my mom my mom's catholic but
she never pushed it upon us when we was
growing up I grew up pretty much with no
religion I'd I've been to church maybe
twice in my life so I wouldn't say I
grew up with a religious okay I don't
think he's misogynistic and I'm also
grew up in a church but my parents
didn't talk to me about marriage until
my 20s because it was you know I was too
young so I've only just discovered and
liked these things and preferred these
things just recently so let me explain
let me explain what uh your vibration
and what you're saying and why a lot of
people watch the show and the importance
of these podcasts is that there's a
frustration that men have dealing with
Western women because they're extremely
masculine they're combative they think
that they're equal they don't make a lot
of sense they talk out of their mouth
they're always on social media and then
when you travel outside of the West and
you see women who are actually feminine
I just spent three weeks in Japan and it
is a breath of fresh air to see women
who are naturally in that state who act
like women who don't prioritize rapping
over being mothers people who are happy
that there's a binary that there's men
and women there's none of this confusion
there's none of this back and forth
there's not this competition that's what
the frustration is is that this is not
natural the way that you're acting your
career path and your dreams your
unwillingness to Define misogyny your
world view is frustrating to deal with
it's not hatred it's I'm trying to
explain that and wide men and probably
why it's going to be difficult for you
to settle down with the husband because
you don't want to submit to a man and
that's how we're going to be happiest
that's why there's a rise in depression
that's why there's a rise in suicide and
antidepressants and all this this is the
root of the problem is feminism it's
it's not it has nothing to do with
hatred it has nothing to do with that
but me hating you I honestly don't care
about you I probably wouldn't talk to
you if this wasn't on a podcast I'm
trying to explain a feeling that a lot
of people are gravitating to and why red
pill is blowing up so much because it's
tapping into this feeling that a lot of
people realize now and they don't really
know why but this is what it is can I
say something quickly do you know why I
like African men more in terms of like
my taste because culturally the same way
that you're saying when you when you
decide the West when you go outside the
West when I go outside the West I'm more
likely to find your average guy as an
African man who has done a lot more
money things the West the men in the
west actually they are a bit soft in the
sense of yeah you can go make your money
and have a career but being a man is
more than the money in your pocket so
actually the problem goes both ways
there's a lot of men that are not doing
what they're meant to do as naturally
masculine men no absolutely and I mean I
always say because I travel around quite
a lot you know I've been to Eastern
Europe and also into
um uh into South America as well when
you go outside of the west where do you
go outside of the Anglo sphere you see
the difference you see and a lot of this
stuff that we're talking about now is
very culturally defined it's very it's a
it's a hot House of this debate that's
going on in England and it's going on in
America and it's going on in Canada and
Australia outside of the these places
very very different it doesn't exist
yeah and my point is that it's not
really what you naturally want you've
been programmed by social media you've
been programmed I guarantee you listen
to Meg the stallion and cardi B you
follow a lot of celebrities on Instagram
and I guarantee you have a lot of
provocative pictures on Instagram this
is this is what happens when you follow
that path and when you think that being
a mother is comparable to being a cow
it's not what you naturally want you
have been brainwashed you wouldn't be
with a woman who makes more than you so
you'll brainwashed yourself babe you
would find it emasculating like you
don't like the fact that there's women
now who can earn the same amount as you
doing the same thing as you actually
earn more than you doing the same thing
as you name one relationship where
that's working and I've asked you the
same question and you couldn't so what's
your plan what is your relationship
where are the man's in charge and the
man makes more can I tell a factual
story my parents
um sorry cardi B one of the biggest
rappers actually came out on Twitter and
she said she wants to stop rapping and
just focus on raising her children
because that's what makes her happy so
do you still feel like you know being a
rapper is what's going to give you
genuine happiness if the biggest rapper
in the world is willing to give that up
she got cash
and they sell you a lie they go on a
song and say I don't cook I don't clean
and then they really want to or Beyonce
will make a song All the Single Ladies
and she's married so they're good and
stayed with a guy that she did and
they're instilling this brainwashing
because it sounds good because it makes
you feel empowered it gives you dopamine
in the moment but it's not really what
gives you long-term serotonin actual
happiness actual higher purpose it's a
drug it's like smoking a cigarette can
you can you hunt
yeah I can yeah can you fight of course
okay that's good yeah
I'm fighting this is so you're good
you're you're still a hot man deep down
even though you started a career online
looking for trouble you're still a man
no I didn't start it there's a lot of
men there's a lot of men that can't do
that I'll ask them can you hunt them
like
um can you tell them to and this is the
reason that Justin wall is so successful
and why people like need this online is
because men can't live in this I don't
believe in I'm not gonna say you need to
improve or else you're going to fall
behind yeah women can believe in this
delusional they can just believe in
nothing they can say I'm going to be a
rapper with cats when I'm 65 and then
people won't check you and if I do check
you I'm misogynistic when you uplift men
and you tell them the truth it's like yo
thank you for telling me that I need to
improve women don't want to hear it they
want to stay in this cycle of nothing
yeah I guess I mean because obviously
you're not sitting here with guys that
are not like you then you can't sit in
obviously say yes
I do I have my friends from back in the
day from back in New York a lot of them
are still in the same spot that they
were in college and I tell them man like
you gotta you got to step your game
that's good so I'll talk to them the
same way so you know it sounds
aggressive but that people need to hear
that I don't know because no one talks
them like that okay so that's nice
because you saying that and you being
able to own up to own up to that brings
more balance to your argument because
the problem is when we sit in these
conversations we're usually saying women
women well the difference is the men for
the men to get out of this podcast
here's the difference you can just be a
girl and be on this podcast we don't
really care what you've done to be a man
of this podcast you've had to have done
something yeah they're not just gonna
you think they're gonna go to a club and
like recruit guys to be here yeah yeah
you wouldn't sit here these guys are
accomplished in their field that's why
we get to sit down with average women
and you know why you get to sit down
with average women not me included
because
because actually there's a massive need
and uh
but then there's also a moment where you
have to chill out because you're not
actually speaking to just average women
you don't actually know it's from
anywhere so when you have an attitude of
almost like wanting to make us look
patronize um almost what we say with
such a challenge yeah that's why you
come across as misogynist well I need to
get through because this is a common
problem that a lot of guys face she
started off by saying she's vibrating
with misogyny and then you know vibrate
and not me and my what I was what I
filtered and then people don't check
that like it's important
what I feel to say
um
actually never mind exactly like you
need to you need to call it out when
people make no sense or else we're gonna
keep living in class can I challenge you
both can I challenge you both
um so
I feel like these new internet men are
like very destructive to these young men
out there because you have of you have
an opinion you have always you're very
vocal about it and you stand strong in
your plane and like you know you've got
this Andrew take passport Rose thing is
that what you're getting at because
you're that's oh going back in different
countries women are feminine
sounding like some nonsense stuff that
other guys jump because the guy's never
gonna look at a woman to for influence
like let's be real and real well not
real men a lot of men will not look and
this is where
um in rap and other careers Fields where
women are at the top men will not they
look they don't look at you and think oh
yeah but this person can influence this
this person can influence me or this
person like it can't come from a woman
but whereas if Andrew Tate does it it's
like oh yeah let's jump on a bandwagon
because he's the guy I'm a guy like you
only want to relate to someone because
of yeah
that's happening though is because
people like Tate and you know the
gentleman sitting here are redressing
the balance because they're and the
reason that they've they've been so
popular and they've blown up to such an
extent is because they're going against
what is the prevailing narrative or the
prevailing narrative is basically
telling guys you know be a nice guy
uh buyer flowers you know take on 15
dates you know this kind of thing and
and all of that kind of thing hasn't
worked but the first thing that he said
is that he's a nice guest so we found
what you mean this is a nice guy yeah so
what does that mean then so he's a nice
guy but he's like this and he's like
that like it's not making any sense like
I said these internet boys there's a lot
of men on the internet are being
brainwashed like they are beautiful like
the women okay yeah the women aren't
being brainwashed but yeah we have maybe
a few sensible men who can go you know
you're not gonna go for everything
what do they say why do they say that's
not true what have they said Andrew
Andrew one thing he said not true I
don't disagree with what
Andrew Tate says
he's saying it like there's a way to say
it and I don't know
that's the perfect report these
brainwashing implies that you're lying
that you're feeding him a lie it's not
what I'm saying because you can't refute
any of it it's how I'm saying it and
this is the Western World We prioritize
the way you feel your vibrations of
misogyny over what is true and what's
false but people are not gonna listen
listen to you if you're not telling the
truth what you're saying is flying over
a lot of people's heads or you want no
not mine because I don't believe in what
you're saying anyways like you you said
you know a woman's nature like you don't
you will never know a woman's nature you
don't bleed once a month bro you're
never gonna know no but it's a woman's
nature so what are you talking about
it's a woman's nature female nature
I want to hear from you I just don't you
haven't talked much so yeah I know um I
don't think that's got anything to do
with it and another thing I want to go
back to the misogyny thing I feel like
people just throw around whatever they
feel whatever they want to say but they
don't want to hold accountability for it
like you don't you can just say whatever
you can say whatever but he can't say
the same thing because then he will you
know you will throw a [__] fit can I
challenge the both of you
um I'm sure most of you guys can agree
that men are becoming more feminine
can you kind of understand why that's
forced women to almost become more
masculine
yeah can I just say one thing though
this is why because you've mentioned
Andrew type people like that and
obviously as you said the gentleman here
the reason that those people have risen
to prominence is because
the the West is out of balance right
they are there redressing the balance
they're going against the prevailing
narrative and and the main thing that
they're preaching everybody is
self-improvement because men have to
like you said men have to step up we
don't get a choice to not step up we
can't just say oh well I'm just you know
I'm just living my truth and you know
it's all going to be fine we have to put
in the work otherwise we're just going
to get left on the sidelines women have
more Advantage than that for the most
part but to go back sorry to stop you
just to go back to my question like can
you both understand why women have now
become more masculine so for example
like a woman her husband has left the
family and now she's forced to become a
more masculine and work and just do more
masculine things so would you guys now
look down on her because she's been
forced to play a position that she had
no choice but to yeah but women leave
more marriages than men do
like 80 of divorces are initiated yeah
and women and women always worked they
just worked in the house
like they always worked they were they
were in the field in the plow like if
anything they worked more but the
previous generations but they still kept
the femininity what I'm trying to say is
that women have become more masculine
and I feel like do you guys somewhat
understand why or do you think we're
just waking up and deciding let's just
be feminine because as much as I feel
like feminism is a dark thing there's a
slight part of me that can understand
why women have been forced to play this
masculine role and do you guys even
acknowledge it or just because I still
think it's a mindset so this is why it's
not misogyny is I completely understand
why I think a lot of trans people for
example are men turning into women
because it's getting harder to perform
as a man and so they'd rather go and
become women in that sense if the
brainwashing is equal there's there's an
equal amount of brainwashing on the on
the masculine side to become more
feminine and to paint your nails and to
to act like that and then you see it
being pushed by YouTube and these
platforms they encourage it they clap it
they're very yes Queen they say Yas
Queen to men you see who the men that
are getting propped up in the most
famous pop stars and music celebrity
they're they're all about
you see the agenda and that's the
problem with the world the problem with
the world is actually weak men I in no
way shape or form would ever allow it to
come out of my mouth that it is women's
fault it is weak men that is letting
these things happen
if we if men got together and said this
this promiscuity is [__] if men got
together and said hey we need to step up
and be stronger and be better that is
the only thing that I allow a woman to
actually let go so you can let him take
that masculine role the women hold on
and it's hard for women because they're
like [__] can this [__] do it can he
take care of me or is he going to come
home and cry to me about his job no
seriously like because you come home we
were talking we had a heated
conversation yesterday about why men
should not go cry to their woman I am a
big believer that a man should never cry
or show emotion from a woman and the
reason is because you're if you were to
translate the words he's screaming I
can't take care of the situation you
can't trust me and so the woman's like
man I better get masculine real quick
it's like what you're talking about with
a man dies women are scared that a man
cannot that because men are weak men are
[__] weak and if men were stronger
women could trust them more and let go
and whether you like it or not fall into
that feminine frame because I think
that's what they're naturally
for pins to do so would you say weak men
is the roots of absolutely the weak men
are the biggest problem in the world
we've men are in charge now it used to
be that the the masculine leader the
fighter or somebody like that the the
warrior would lead charged but ever
since technology social media you could
be able to poke girls I say this all the
time Mark Zuckerberg and created
Facebook he was a nerd and he started
like he based Facebook off of hot or not
and so now this nerd was able to go and
uh own the sexual Marketplace he was
able to judge all these women who would
have he would have never had access to
before and that was a shift in 2007 now
the nerd is in charge rather than the
warrior so now that they've acknowledged
that men can be weak would you still say
they're misogynistic
not can be are men are weak and that's
why Andrew is so popular yeah but my
point is that the fact that the both of
you can actually sit here and
acknowledge that man men being weak is
the cause of you know just this
destruction of relationships could you
now see that they are not misogynistic
if they can see both sides of the
you know panel plane whatever the scene
is
no comment
um guys I'm gonna take a second to read
Super Chat um sneako I know you have to
get going are you reason what yeah I got
some time okay okay I don't wanna okay
um so guys I'm gonna read all super
chats that are over 20 so if you want me
to read your super chat um make sure
it's over 20 because we're not reading
the ones below it um okay quickly though
you can give a comment it's okay we
don't need to keep on arguing I don't
understand you don't want to submit and
you think it's suppressing but we can be
on the same page if you can submit to me
then we can be on the same page submit
to what as in my femininity submit to
your feminism come home to her give her
kisses sometimes
for me do what you think a woman needs
to do and have the baby so do you want a
masculine man or a feminine man what
obviously a masculine like obviously men
men don't know each other so if you want
a masculine man if you want a masculine
man then I can't submit to you oh
do you do you want a relationship or not
with somebody not me
definitely because what you're saying
makes no sense like well what am I
saying you're saying that you want me to
submit to you and you want me to cook
and clean for you but also you want to
mask maybe let your guard down a little
bit become more vulnerable that's what
men do you know men do men do clean men
do submissive things do you want a
husband that's gonna cook and clean for
you cooking is not submissive cooking is
just it's a simple question yeah but
he's saying so are you saying that
cooking and cleaning as a man is
submissive yes that's crazy do you want
a husband that cooks and cleans for you
why not okay have you ever been in love
of course okay so when you were with
your girlfriend were you always this
like I'm a man or you're not able to
just like chill out a little bit and
cuddle with her and sometimes she's the
one giving you massage and you're giving
her kisses and being cute to her I've
tried it doesn't work life does work
that's actually quite nice a lot of men
the men that are in a relationship
couldn't do that not anymore okay well
there you go yes no but I do know a lot
of men and I know this because that's
the reason why I always say men talk so
much but they don't know each other as
deep as they think they do because men
change completely in the private company
of a woman as well so that's why power
couples make all the big moves in this
world
I say there are power couples in the
world but I think most couples that are
successful aren't really a power couple
it's just a very very strong man and a
very very supportive onboard woman now
there is Jay-Z and Beyonce but I do
think they're outliers
what's going on in their relation
ship happy to me I'm not gonna lie
there's been public well they're
fighting over who has the dick
honestly in a lot of ways and I don't
think that's healthy at all in no way do
I think a man and a woman in a
relationship should compete for who the
man is going to be and I think that's
probably the overarching problem with
feminism is that you have a man and a
woman in this power struggle over
something that has traditionally been
successful being the man's role and
that's not to belittle a woman is to put
her in her grace and her beauty and
everything that's wonderful about women
it's it's it's a lane thing and and
nobody's you know it's not about being
right or wrong it's like what are we
wired to do I agree with you earlier I
would never drop my children off to a a
daycare with men running it women are
better at it they're nurturing they have
these skill sets it's about that it's
not about you know which one of us are
going to take the lead because I I
cannot find a relationship and I would
challenge you to find a relationship
that's really going to work with a
woman's leader in the alpha how can how
can she respect him and and if she
doesn't respect him how can she love him
I mean there's the Queen Margaret fat
Margaret that show that's a good example
of her being the Prime Minister and I
would call it an outlier I call it an
outlier if you took if you took a
hundred relationships you still probably
wouldn't have the queen or Margaret
Thatcher in it and I can tell you the
more dominant she gets and pearl will
probably admit this the bigger your
channel gets the harder it will be to
find a man on your level because you
make a lot of money facts are you ready
I'm doing okay yeah
but your very base and you do understand
the more influence you get the taller
you are the more money
the harder it is
but you can still find them I absolutely
can I want to correct something it's not
intimidating to guys no guy is
intimidated by what I do uh it's not
intimidating it just doesn't typically
work in relationships and the woman
makes more than the man yeah so they're
a bit more shook to even go no they're
not they're not because they know that
if they go try and try them with pearl
because she's a g and I'm not I'm gonna
get hurt because I may fall in love with
a girl that is not going to look up to
me so I better not go down a bit shook
still I have a question you know that
are taller than you that make more money
than you how many
um
not not many
um but yeah I know a couple but not many
yeah
I have a question oh is your like
podcasts more important to you than like
settling down and having children
now
no it's not okay then that's nice so
you're gonna abdicate of the jpt team so
once say you was to find someone not to
like interview but if say you was to
find someone and they would want you to
like give up this whole podcast thing
and you are in love with them to have a
family would you do it yeah oh that's so
refreshing to hear yeah it's all the
equipment though I need to get my money
back
to you guys he tell you to put in
storage you know that's one of those
things but that's kind of what makes her
a hero in a lot of ways because she's
sitting here doing this thing that's
going to counteract really finding that
dude and and she's out here telling so
many women Hey listen you're probably
going to be more happy like this at the
expense of honestly herself in a lot of
ways this is a very expensive Penthouse
right it's a very big Channel she has
it's like people talk about boss [__]
like she's employing a lot of people you
know like you want to talk about God's
work like shout out to Pearl for that
you know I'll argue with you on a
subject if we have to but let's call it
Spade of spade what she's doing is
pretty selfless in that regard
yeah I guess so should make plenty of
money as well from that it makes it hard
it's gonna make it harder for her
because even she knows she could get a
man right but the likelihood of him
being like what are you 5 11. six six
yeah six foot tall yeah six foot tall so
that that that's down to one percent of
the male population right before the
money right before the money and and the
clout
like think about you're talking about
point zero zeros or put that in the
delusion calculator and you guys still
aren't listening to what I mean Katie
Perry's her net worth is higher than her
husband she did all right so well I mean
what other option do I have a Die Alone
um
okay I'm gonna Read Super chats
guys make sure you like the video and
subscribe to the channel okay
um God of Legends and why sneako has on
why does snico have on feminine pants um
that is like skinny jeans women wore in
the 90s he is wearing hey man he is
wearing um pure
um nut hugger pants
um Gora Legends um true that's why snico
got his uh skinny jeans from the female
Department Lucifer I'm a question for
the guys do you Jay Waller Troy and
snico have girlfriends who are providing
value to you as you speak and if so what
is the value are your woman actually
helping you build your Empire how or so
you guys preach a lot that's actually a
good question um that we can come back
to
um Nestle hustle um here is 20 for the
rapper chick to stop talking
um Jasmine what wish the women would
respond with an educational response
instead of an emotional one they're so
defensive and make it about themselves
instead of answering the question was
just logic and justification
um
Lawrence Bullock on the goal of feminism
is to erase the difference between men
and women not equality Lawrence so any
criticisms of women is misogyny direct
from the feminism handbook
silly sausage hungry managed to find a
way to help monetize motherhood by
lowering income tax 25 for every child
that they have forever um four kids no
tax and guess what the feminist thought
about that you guessed right they hated
it
zero fall out the myth of the
stay-at-home wife needs to be needs to
die throughout history the majority of
women have always worked in some way be
it in farms field the home or at the
market only in recent times as the
average been able to has the average
been able to have one
um Manny F during World War one and two
women had to go to factories and work in
order to support the men there in war
and still took care and still took care
of the children then lived a much harder
life how are women today suppressed and
what would the panel do and would the
panel of women do the same sacrifice Ash
I'm showing my support from
showing my support your Chi-Town brother
keep Aiming High
and Let me refresh it really quick
um okay so what was the question that
they asked you guys I want to find it
again okay
do you guys have girlfriends providing
value to you as you speak and if so what
is the value are your women actually
helping you build your Empire how so
yeah I have a couple girlfriends right
now I know it's Haram but one of them
runs my Discord server and she's she's
on top of things when I was getting a
lot in a lot of drama she was there and
she was able to take care of it and make
sure that it was running properly I have
one that wants to become my assistant
and I'm training her to run my
accounting and do the taxes and do the
paperwork when I get tickets I'm going
to try to get her to quit her job and be
my assistant the other one uh working on
traveling with her and she recently got
a big payout so I'm gonna go travel with
her and she's there she helps me find
other girls as well so and the other one
the other one needs work but all of them
add something to my life and all of them
help
then play their role properly if they
were completely useless I think that
it's not worth my time or theirs
for you there's no woman in my life it's
not an asset to me
you think like a pimp and love and
profile like a hero straight up like
there's no woman it's not an asset
what about you what was the question
again sorry um do you have girlfriends
providing you value as you speak and if
so what is the value
I mean yeah absolutely they all provide
value because otherwise why would you
spend time with them right I mean but
the way that they provide value is is
um not material but it's sort of like in
terms of sustenance in terms of in terms
of feminine energy it's in terms of you
know having somebody there who kind of
gets you
um there's many many ways in which they
provide value 100 percent
so I have a question for the women um do
you want to be married and have kids yes
um if so what age do you want to be
buried and how many kids I would love to
be married with kids tomorrow but
um that's not happening because I still
need to work on myself
um I would ideally like to do that like
25 25 how many kids do you want I want
four four kids okay what about you um I
would like to be married I would like to
have children
um maybe my late 20s I haven't really
thought too much into it but how do you
know I'm 22. I've never been in a
relationship so I haven't really got an
exact age where
I would say I want to get married I
don't feel like I need to meet someone
first to put a time frame on it why late
20s late 20s yeah
um
I just feel like I want to travel and
live my life to the fullest and then
when I'm ready to be selfless then I'm
ready to settle down and have children
and start a family wouldn't you prefer
to travel with your husband I would love
to travel with someone I travel a lot on
my own so it would be nice to travel
with someone what does live your life
mean I hear that a lot from from good
girls like you and then live your life
in if we're going to be honest what does
live your life really mean you're
traveling living your life what come on
to travel and to live my life honestly I
think travel was the best education that
you can get I think it's better than any
school that you can go through I think
you learn about the real world when you
travel you learn about different
cultures you meet so many different
people and that's why I love to travel
do you think you're gonna have an easier
time finding your husband now when
you're 22 you haven't had a relationship
or when you're in your late 20s and
you've already I will definitely
um definitely earlier on but to get
married because obviously you're not
going to meet someone straight away and
get married to them in an instant you're
going to have a relationship with them
first I assume anyway
um so yeah I could meet someone when I'm
like 25 and then I could get married
when I'm 28 but that's still
yeah can I chime in in the conversation
I it's clear that the point that you're
trying to make is that you're the
younger you are the better chances you
have of finding someone I think you
should start looking now instead of put
it off but I think I think I think it'll
be okay
I think when it happens it happens kind
of thing I'm not gonna go out of my way
and and search for it and make it my
sole purpose but I think when the time
is right
um the world will give me someone that's
meant for me
so can I ask you a question so do you
think um age is an indicator for you as
to picking a partner like is it is it
like if she's older then you don't want
her if she's younger it's pretty like
preferably your your
type of woman has to be between a
certain age Etc or have you like
is well what's your name by the way me
yeah Dania Danielle is like a perfect
example of a girl that I would date that
I would like to go out with 22 hasn't
had a relationship uh very pretty I
would rather date her now than when she
was 32 and travel the world completely
agree
you know why
because a man that's traveled the world
like we've all done here
we know that the girl that has Instagram
photos and multiple multiple countries
was not only living her life but
statistically I slept with a lot more
men
you know what I'm saying that's what
life means yeah that's what the journey
means and we call it the [__] Carousel
and I don't mean to be crude but
a woman that has been more promiscuous
and traveled more and done all these
different things then what do you have
to give her that's going to make her
life magic anyway so when we're talking
about being the hero and wanting like no
man wants a woman that he can't save
from a castle on a dragon that doesn't
mean the woman needs to be saved or
she's broken that's the beautiful thing
about love so if she's done all the
experience for example if you get in a
Lamborghini and you know how to use the
handle on the door it tells me something
you understand what I'm saying now if
you can't get in you're like how does it
like when a girl gets in my G-Wagon if
she can't like I'm like huge turn on nah
I want to show you the world Danielle I
don't want someone else to show you
but does what I'm saying makes sense
like a man wants a woman that has
preserved herself in many many ways like
you have no relationships so if if a
woman has done
um any sort of sex work it's not oh
that's completely out obviously yeah
that's very obvious yeah I would never
wife up a girl that her job was to have
sex with men no that's absolutely
foolish but hoes get wife the quickest
yeah because they're samps they're the
easiest one and then it fails because
they don't the the hoe or the the sex
worker doesn't want to have sex for
money any longer so she finds some fool
to pay for her life and then she texts
me and I'll sleep with her are you on
only fans no not me oh do you understand
what I'm saying like that's like no
quality man no man that's going to be
worth this salt is going to pick up a
sex worker no
why would he have to because if he's
high level he can get a girl like her
and I don't even mean that to be
disrespectful like I'm not trying to
disrespect sex workers I'm telling you
right now I would never marry one well
first of all marriage is a different
subject but I would never make her you
know pretty serious part of my life at
all ever but then don't you pay for it
who pays for it no I'm just saying
because as men I have this um ideology
no I said every woman is an asset okay a
man's job is to build a woman to the
woman that it takes to take her where
he's going interesting build her a man
should build a woman
and and that means by investing into her
like hey baby I just said this yesterday
it's like Hey listen we're gonna go to
this event I'm gonna get you this dress
do it like this little less titties the
for the forks start here and go in you
wanna you wanna build her up and make
her be able to come up because you're
trying to get up the social classes
right if you really love her you're a
developer and build her to take her with
you that's what you do for a woman
that's how you build a woman but a woman
that's been giving her body away to all
the other guys at the table because the
rich guys that pay for sex they'd be
like I had that girl last year in morbea
bye yeah no [__] way no [__] way
oh hey do you want to be married
skip me please
um I marriage in the traditional sense
is not really something that bothers me
I'd rather have oh you want to do the
two houses thing don't you I'd rather
have a partnership and I'd rather have a
man present in my life but it doesn't
have to be like overwatching and
overwhelming with the way that people
are making it seem nowadays like I fully
agree with what you're saying I think
that for me to be able to actually take
a man very seriously it has to be a man
that can actually bring something new to
my life you know with somebody that I
can look up to and I can be like okay
you're teaching me something new that
okay I need you to answer the question
do you want to be married yes or no I
want to have a partnership marriages
okay okay so you don't care about being
married on paper now you want a
relationship yeah okay okay do you want
kids yes or no yeah definitely okay how
many kids
in the world of today I think it's safe
to have two two kids okay and you're 30.
yes um so when do you want to be in a
relationship and when do you want to
have the kids uh since it's just been
about like a year since I've rebuilt my
life
um I'd say maybe like
I'll probably pick my husband about six
months okay so in the next six months
you're gonna find a house do you have
some prospects yeah of course okay
seriously you got you got a list I've
got I've well anyone anyone in the chat
and he's ready to marry you within six
months yeah okay and so then you're
gonna or no sorry not getting married
but being that in a relationship it's
very listen and then when do you when do
you want your first kid bye
um I mean I don't really go into people
to meet people superficially I tend to
go quiet
so wait wait I'm just giving you 31 32
33 34 35 maybe like it depends on how
the relationships
it's not about age about how many
minutes
no no essentially I'm not gonna say I
want to have a kid by 31. I mean you're
running out of eggs well I do and
actually just being 30 doesn't mean you
don't have eggs
geriatric pregnancy starts at 35. that's
fine I got five years okay okay
what age what age do you want to have
your first kid
I would like to have my first kid uh
when me and my husband have established
that we are ready you just said you
don't want to be married well okay that
talking out of both sides of the mouth
once again okay
once me and my son my hubby yeah which
not on paper but in life wants me
established that we can't get on then
we're ready for the thing that's it I'm
not gonna say I want these kids when
he's not ready okay so you're gonna have
the kids when he's ready when we're both
ready okay so conversation okay yeah I
wanna all right when when do you want to
be married how many kids do you want and
what age do you want to have kids um I
want to be married by 25 and I want to
have two kids by 30 and then my third
kid before I'm 35. yeah how old are you
now 19. oh okay yeah
19 that's good yeah lots of really good
ones that to have at 19. that's really
good thanks
um
so I'm 21.
um I am
want to be married by 25 that's my aim
and then children I want as soon as
possible once I'm married yeah how many
I like kids so four maybe four kids four
kids yeah four kids
but then again I don't know I think I've
got a major problem because
I'm finding it very difficult to find
the right person and I don't know if I'm
the problem or if it's the men or what
are you looking for
um someone definitely more dominant than
me
um I feel like as if I've gone too far
down the career route and I've obviously
I'm only 21. I've done it a lot okay
what have you done
um so I've got my dream job I'm an
executive assistant uh so that was like
what I wanted to do I work for a really
big family I've got my dream car
um and then for me to go out there and
try to find a man who's able to beat
that because obviously that's what women
want they want someone bigger than them
someone stronger someone more masculine
dominant but then I can't find that I
don't know why I do know why because
we're surrounded by very weak men
unfortunately
so mighty boys yeah
yeah I'm not gonna speak too much do you
have like an income requirement yeah how
much does he have to make
um
I would say about
at least 25 more than me and many
languages which is roughly it will have
to be in like the 40 45 48 000 kind of
Mark okay so that's like in US Dollars
that's like 55.60 yeah something like
that you can find that guy yeah that's
not crazy can I say something just
quickly too no no I'm gonna I'm gonna so
um I'm curious to the guys what are the
best places for women to find husbands
that's a good question
nowadays A lot of it happens online a
lot of people Instagram DM but I think
like you should go put yourself in
situations where I think the farmer's
market go grocery shopping
I think the church you should go find a
guy there
a picnic like a little Park you know
just go to cute places I met I met a lot
of great couples recently in Japan they
met at the beach you know I don't I
think that if you are in your feminine
nature and you are doing things that
coincide with that you'll you could find
that guy
I hear a lot of females say um there's a
whole lot of accounts on Tick Tock that
base their content off of how to find a
successful rich man or how to do this or
how to do that
um and they usually say they usually
Target Mayfair Knightsbridge go to this
bar go to this club I wouldn't I
wouldn't seek that out I I don't
immediately you put yourself in the
scenario that guys at that level I'm not
looking for you don't want a girl who's
clubbing I think the I think what sneako
said is is important being in your
feminine energy where wherever you go
you're gonna more likely attract a
better quality of man because the
problem with Mayfair and you know
Kensington and Knightsbridge in these
places is you're going to meet a lot of
guys who just want to have one night
stands but equally you're going to meet
them online as well so
um it's it's really about the energy
that you put out in terms of what you
attract but I think as well going to
some more like chilled out places going
to borrow a market like he said go to
Whole Foods you know those kind of
places more likely to meet somebody
who's a bit more authentic than maybe
the most beneficial glamorous yeah yeah
Jim's good although as long as you don't
start filming him and putting it on
please don't do that
what do you think
it's hard because it depends on what you
mean how you define the man right Whole
Foods I don't grocery shop anymore so I
don't think you're gonna find a one
percenter in there but at the same time
you know
you have to find them somewhere so I
think sneako's dead on with the online
thing and then it comes down to
filtering and asking the right questions
but being respectful inside those
questions you know say and just be hat
in hand honest like look man I'm looking
for this kind of guy you know and 50 60
Grand he also nailed that that's not
going to be a problem for you in fact I
wouldn't be surprised if you got a bunch
of messages after this show because
that's so very obtainable now right so
you need to aim higher yeah and I think
you could I think I think you can get a
higher okay yeah you could
but um you know also you have to
understand that guys that are pretty
well to do have pretty well to do
Hobbies bro if I was a girl I'd be
playing golf like a [__] you
know what I'm saying even if you suck
yeah even if you're trash even if you're
trash you know so it's like those types
of things you know where where do where
do guys like that meet up where are they
and can it not be in a bar scene because
you don't want to meet somebody you're
going to be with forever in a bar
because the first question you're gonna
get asked is you have to carry that
around in your relationship oh we met in
the club right so I I would try not to
meet a person in the club honestly So
when you say the best place to meet
someone is online how do you portray
yourself in the best way possible online
what is your ideal ideally if you want
to be wife material I would make it be
known that you had curves without
showing skin okay there's a classy way
to be sexy right you know the woman
that's like very clearly built well but
is not showing it but she's still
showing it just there's clothes right
yeah with a bit of mystery to right and
it'll drive men wild because now if you
go online and you look at a girl's
account and first of all she's got the
cleavage everywhere but if you just
scroll down a little bit you can see
exactly what her nipples look like I
don't want a woman like that I don't
want that you know why because a man
gets a lot of value from other men out
of how classy and how beautiful this
woman is and if she's out there
promoting it to the world number one
that's marketing so I would never accept
that as a man personally and then number
two everybody in that group is going to
look down upon that man because the
woman is out there marketing and they've
all seen everything he's got so the
sacredness and and which is one of the
most beautiful things I believe that a
woman has is now given away so it's I
think it's very important to compete
because you are competing against bbos
and boob jobs and all those things but
even if you get a boob job there's a way
to show that you have big boobs and a
busty figure and you're in good shape
without actually showing it if that
makes sense
do you what do you think about women
that get plastic surgery to attract men
you think that's a good idea I think
you're smart I would do it if I was if I
was a woman I would have fake boobs for
sure if I didn't have you know you
understand what I'm saying yeah let's
not cap about that and I'll also be in
the squat rack and I'll also be doing
all the things that it took to attract
men beauty is very mathematical in a lot
of ways the attractive things about a
woman like as far as bust and shape and
all those things those things are very
very very real and although it sounds
shallow it's the basis of the
relationship is attraction so if you can
be attracted to somebody and then be and
then another thing I would be
at least well read understand politics
have a strong opinion because you're
going to want those kind of things
because I do there is nothing more
attractive for me than a woman that is
based
if a woman is based like we'll have a
strong opinion about the right things
yeah if you're a communist I don't want
to yeah like I mean I mean obviously a
feminist right and here's a news flash
for you most most successful men are
based in pretty much conservative if
you're talking politics right that's by
and largely and then if you get a lefty
that's successful he's probably going to
be kind of Simply you're probably going
to sacrifice some masculinity there you
know so for me the right Hobbies I like
the I like the whole foods thing but
online and then make sure you're the
kind of class that a man says okay I can
take her and like turn her and build her
and keep developing her because she's
already on the right path she's already
the right cloth men often pick the wrong
cloth as do women
but having to be in the right Claw from
the jump you're giving that man a canvas
to turn you into a queen
so that's what I would do can I ask the
question like I understand what
femininity looks like from a woman's
perspective but from a man's eyes like
what does femininity look like to you
guys because I might have a we might
have different opinions I don't think we
do oh really okay so what do you what do
you think the woman's perspective on I
think femininity is someone who's calm
someone who's able to submit someone
who's able to compromise thousand
someone who takes care of herself and
you got you guys just have the same
thing I think you want to be looking at
watchwords like classy demure modesty
you know and when you're constructing
say like an online profile it's those
kinds of things you want to be going for
like like Justin has just said I mean
you can look sexy but nice dress you
know not not going the sort of the
Instagram hoe kind of Route you know
less is more you know in it with a lot
of these things yeah because you're
selling it cheaper yeah yeah
oh that's true do any of you guys have
any other dating questions for the guys
if you'd want to know from like a man's
point of view
uh what do you think is the main problem
with men nowadays and the women that
they choose like why are they making
certain mistakes I think that ethics
happen a long time before you need them
so men
choose not to be in abundance in every
area of their life they're not taking
care of their Fitness they're not taking
care of their business they're not
taking care of their career their style
they're not well read They're not doing
all the things that they're supposed to
be able to do to tell a woman that comes
into their life Hey listen I can't put
up with this kind of behavior you can't
have your titties all over the internet
I can't accept that you have to be an
abundance to tell a woman no the woman
then this is not to disrespect women but
a woman needs to know that you can
replace her you need to be that kind of
man to earn that kind of respect from a
woman and when you can get in a position
with a woman where she knows you can
replace her with somebody else that
wants to be classy who wants to take
that role who wants to be submissive
inside a frame that you've earned then
you're in the right place and Men by and
largely are not doing that now they're
playing the video games and doing the
weed or whatever they're not supposed to
be doing and for that reason they make
sacrifices when it comes down to
relationship negotiations that they
shouldn't make and they don't even want
to make but that's the only girl they
got yeah and so if they would have been
working on themselves the last few years
they when it comes to the point of
something coming to a head they can't
look a woman in the eyes with conviction
and say this isn't going to work I'm
going to run I'm gonna be the leader in
this relationship they have to cater but
that wouldn't and what happens with that
is she sees him Buckle because he's not
in abundance and then she loses respect
for him and if she doesn't leave him she
cheats what about the mistake that a lot
of athletes make because they also seem
to end up sometimes with like absolutely
so there's pockets in life so the money
bucket can fill up you can be the
richest guy in the world and be a
[__] dork you can also be completely
jacked ripped you know Alpha half game
all those other things be broke so a man
can't just stop at one thing so if you
were look at like a schedule of values
of things in life you have to be
connected you have to have influence you
have to have money you have to be fit
you have to be worldly well spoken and
be able to be articulate in a
conversation and communicate because a
woman is really going to need
communication because it's going to get
emotional you know so you better have to
be Stern and direct but at the same time
a good communicator without arguing a
man has to have emotional intelligence I
will never raise my voice at a one like
a woman I'm seeing I'll never raise my
voice because it tells her that I'll go
down to a child level she has to respect
me there has to be that dissonance
because if she doesn't respect me she's
like man I need to find a guy I respect
I don't look up to this guy this guy
can't handle it yeah this guy is
childish he'll come down here with me
yeah that's not the way to do it so
for me a man has to handle all these
different areas of his life and some of
these buckets feel and that's what
you'll see sometimes you'll see a guy
get ran over the coals because he's an
athlete so he had let's say maybe
Fitness and money but he didn't have all
those other things like frame and things
like that to make him a leader and the
next thing you know he's getting he's
getting divorced like that soccer player
yeah yeah that just got wrecked right
nope he didn't get wrecked he actually
won in that divorce something did he
yeah because she makes more money than
him secondly right well but let's take
any athlete that gets wrecked it happens
they get wrecked because they they look
at that one bucket particularly a money
bucket a lot of times you see a lot of
fat Rich guys they get comfortable they
think they're the big boss but there's
dudes out there competing in every
category yeah and you have to and you
have to have the frame right I have a
very burning question that's been asked
okay one second sneako has to go so um
thank you yeah thanks for coming to
answer this question real quick real
quick okay I have a very abundant
question that's been answered a million
times but I really need to like um I
still don't understand why do men cheat
like what are the top five reasons
it's just now it's just on our DNA it's
never gonna stop I don't even think it's
worth asking that question just accept
it if you want that level of guy you
gotta accept it so there's no reason
there's just a natural thing that they
just cheat it's natural for us to do
that yeah could you expand on that
well the first thing I would say is that
a man will you call it cheating I think
a real man is going to tell you how he's
going to be from the jump there's
honesty it's the deceit that's the
problem every woman knows that if a man
could he would you know so I think the
deceit and not only deceit is that a lot
of times what happened is you the man
himself is not even showing up how he's
supposed to he's supposed to make this
commitment to provide and protect and
make your life this wonderful place and
he doesn't and on top of that he's a
liar and he's a coward because he was
scared of you to tell you you understand
what I'm saying like that is the most
deceitful thing on the planet because a
lot of times when the man is [__] the
woman expects sexual exclusivity but
they don't really expect it from like we
talked about yesterday they're not
really expecting from Drake now are they
you know what I'm saying so it's when a
guy doesn't show up he lies and he's a
coward where a woman's like okay I'm
leaving for sure leaving but if a man
were to sit down tell the truth be bold
and and a woman is based enough to say
you know what any man on the planet if
he could be rich Paul powerful
handsome whatever it is
he would absolutely have all the women
that he wanted I think the thing that
women
mistake when it comes to the subject of
infidelity or sleeping with women is
that they feel like he must love her or
that they're on the same level as the
other woman because a lot of times a
woman is less attractive that's not true
it's just it's just different and and
men and women women often tend to have
sex when they have true feelings for a
man men are just not that way
you know so it's it's the difference
between the Sexes but I think what's I
think women already know that it's the
deceit and the cowardness and the lack
of performance from the man that makes a
woman leave for that because if you got
a real good man that's a real good
father a real good husband a real
provider a real partner a real Rider
like somebody that'll sit down with you
when you're crying about it and like
really be there for you and hold and not
cry with you because we ain't crying
around here but but be there for you
truly and you know that they got you in
every way and you trust them and look up
to them and they're building you and
making you better dude you're not
leaving that guy no way
even if it hurts it even if you're gonna
say no right now
I've experienced it enough to know that
I'm right do high value men cheat every
one of them
no that's not true that's actually not
true 99
thank you for giving that one percent I
appreciate it I don't want a cap I think
99 though yeah oh wait can we get 95
95 plus Pearl's Dad
thank you thank you and that's the thing
though because it used to trigger you a
year ago right when we'd have this
conversation we've done whole shows
about this yeah and now it doesn't I
think that you see it through a whole
nother lens the whole show last night
was about it in the beginning the show
the girls were pissed by the end they
were like I'd stay
you know and and it's it's just this
ugly truth about the word I don't like
it I'll say I told every girl last night
I would pay a million dollars to cut
that feeling off it is in us I saw
something a podcast the other day where
a man said if a man cheats women
shouldn't take it personal or should
they should just suck it up do you agree
because I don't think well so I don't
like that idea of just sucking it up if
you if you if she's like truly truly
hurt by it I think you need to sit in it
with her and be there for her like I
look a real man can slit a throat and
hold a baby in the same day that's my
definition of a man so you have to be
able to do both you know you need to be
hard hard hard and loving and there's no
problem being vulnerable with a woman or
like hey being there for her there's no
problem at all because if you're really
strong if anybody takes it tries to take
advantage of your vulnerability you
[__] crush them so wait you don't
there's not one woman on this Earth not
one woman fully commit to
no no no no no no no yes there are there
are women that I can fully commit to as
in you sexually no there's no no and
there's no man that would want to
if you lined up every man on the planet
and you said Hey listen I got this red
button I've said this on podcast before
nobody's looking nobody's gonna judge
you truly nobody's here every man in the
world they said you can be a great
husband a wonderful father you can go
home tuck your kids at night possibly
sleep with other women and then go home
and hold your wife and tuck in your
babies and provide and be a good husband
and father every man on the planet would
look left they'd look right and they'd
hit that button do you think cheating is
a good thing
no but it is just naturally part of the
male psyche it's it's what I think the
point the point is it's it's it's he can
absolutely love the woman you know she
can be his absolute Queen she is like
the the top
um but he's always gonna have that that
propensity to what variety that's what
it comes down to and like Justin said
that the other the other woman doesn't
even need to be that good she doesn't
even need to be as attractive she could
be ugly yeah I think these girls really
miss that and that whole time
the one he actually loves has the
ability probably to break his heart yeah
and and girls often ask well what's the
difference because I always thought that
if a man cheats he truly doesn't love
him oh no that's not true at all that's
not true at all that's not true at all
you know look I'm telling you right now
honey hungry and horny to a man's the
same thing you have filet mignon at home
but sometimes you just eat a corn dog
because it's different so would you say
a hole is a hole
do you if it's female like well I got
certain standards right so you know no a
hole is not a hole but at the same time
you would be surprised at how far down
the totem pole a man would go for
variety and they don't love what they
don't love these women they don't even
want them in their bed what if a dude
got another girl pregnant do you think
that the girl should leave
no
no because because it's really about him
showing up the way he's supposed to show
up women know men are this way all women
in their gut truly know men are this way
and a lot of times it's acceptable man
there's so many rap songs out there
talking about infidelity and [__]
hoes and [__] and the girls in the
club just dancing what do you what do
you think are valid reasons for
women-ending relationships a man not
holding the correct frame not being the
man of the house being weak being in a
position where he's not being the leader
not taking responsibility not stepping
up not being a man specific like example
um just like in a day-to-day
relationship of how that would play out
day-to-day relationship
I'll give you a great example men get
married every weekend in America
they stand in front of the church God
and both families and commit to the
woman
they tell her they're gonna basically
saying they're gonna give her the best
life they've made an agreement for that
man to work his ass off he comes home
he's complaining about his job but
instead of getting out there and
hustling and creating a better life for
them and to be a better father and a
better husband he pops open a beer
smokes a j and turns on the Xbox
and he's just
emotionally vomited all over his wife
which puts her in a position of feeling
fearful like this guy he's coming home
complaining about his job not doing a
[__] thing about it and then dumping
it on me now I have to work so we can
make the mortgage now our kids not might
have to go to a lesser School than they
would have our whole situation is [__]
because this guy didn't make a
commitment and he's fine with that
because he's going to trade off sex
right but here's a news flash his ass
will cheat on you too and when you find
out you're gonna leave him but the guy
that's taking care of business every way
making you feel safe giving you a life
that you'd have never had otherwise has
committed to you
and your happiness and even is there
when you're emotionally upset or feeling
pain that's the kind of man you want
a man again my definition is a man is
somebody that can slit a throat and hold
a baby in the same day and that really
sums it up because he's got to be hard
he's got to be strong but he can still
be delicate if it needs to be because
he's so strong that he knows that he can
snap out of that really really fast
and that's it I still think cheating is
disgusting of course agreed if a woman
cheated on you would you stay [__] no no
it's a complete double standard it's not
fair at all I agree it's a complete
double standard it's not fair at all but
you know what I know well if a woman
truly loves a man she doesn't see other
men and then she can't even see them
I agree with that because there's been
times when I really like someone and it
doesn't matter how attractive another
person is see you straight to him that's
just I'm not interested yeah but a man
that creates an atmosphere of of being a
real man creates real genuine desire and
it takes genuine desire to make other
men invisible when other men are
invisible that's when you're doing it
right
when I have a Facebook account full of
wives slotting in my DMs I know all
those dudes aren't doing it right
yeah Facebook's the worst
Facebook can I ask you a question so
obviously you mentioned online and but I
genuinely feel like a lot of men are
looking for wives in whole houses right
in whole houses
figuratively yeah basically you're
picking the wrong woman you're looking
for a lot of men are kind of like going
for women just bumping into them like in
the club what they're looking for where
they can find an easy woman because it
may say that the chase is a lot easier
what is the best physical place for a
man to meet a wife in your opinion
physical place yes in like real life not
online ideally it would be in the gym
for me I'm real big on Fitness like gym
okay but what I'll say about those guys
that are shopping in whorehouses is it
kind of goes back to they didn't do the
work to be in abundance so
I've slept with a bunch of Instagram
models right I would never never take
them seriously why
because their titties are all over the
Internet and that's that is a problem
it's a big problem yeah I get that too
because she didn't keep that secret yeah
but you could cover her up
if she changed the whole account
immediately maybe but that's a big maybe
but if you could do it that means that
the guys probably did it as well isn't
it like in itself right exactly but but
the thing too is this is like so the the
more simp guy the more the guy that
didn't take care of his business the guy
that's not in abundance in his life
he'll take her immediately because
that's the hottest girl he can get yeah
but he's picking the wrong cloth it goes
back to what we talked about earlier
about like what makes a woman look good
for a high level Man online it's being
the right cloth you can show that you're
built well without showing the assets
themselves yeah it's interesting that
you said that he could cover her up
though because if sneakode said that
said oh I could I'll just cover her up
you just said he was misogynist
[Music]
um
but you're right
maybe maybe and maybe they got off on
the on their own foot I think some men
have unrealistic standards though in
what way
because you said that you would meet
your ideal partner in the gym so she
could be like a gym or work or anywhere
normal I think what not a club I think
it's not the venue I think it's not the
venue so much I mean yeah I'd agree not
a club but I think it's not build that
it's not the venue so much it's it's
does the guy have a decent vetting
system in place like is he and you're
right if you don't have
any abundance you know if this girl that
you've met who maybe you know she's got
some questionable morals or she's not
ideal for you but she's the best that
you've ever got you're going to cling on
to that like it's your life depends on
it right and actually what you need to
do is have the power not to do that you
know to let a woman go even if she's
incredibly beautiful you know to like
with the instagrammables you know just
let her go because she's not right for
you okay so you and you've got to you've
got a vet you've got to know what you're
looking for and you've got to stick to
those um those boundaries that you have
for yourself so another question for you
too other than obviously the physical
appearance what other ways do you spot
red flags in a woman what's your trick
well how do you filter through what you
say is decent what is not in terms of
like the mentality the things you can't
actually see you've got to look at their
behavior I think yeah like if she's if
she slept with you on the first date are
you not going to take her serious
yeah that's the real thing because we I
think women feel like a real attraction
and a pool to someone that you really
like like because in that time is that
it's an innate behavior I'll tell you
this I have felt women not sleep with me
on a first date knowing they wanted to
just to try to defend against that and
then and I think it's a smart move I
respect it but what what attracts me
just as much as you well not as much as
Beauty I don't think that's fair but a
woman that's level-headed and based
where can I buy that by base so okay
cool
so I just said something that you don't
like right but you're intelligent enough
to have a real conversation and not go
boom Off the Wall can't hear what I'm
saying anymore we can have a real
conversation that's intellectually
attractive that's a smart thing to do
you know what I'm saying like that's how
a woman can be like you sit in it it's
the combative women the ones that want
to argue with you and everything's a
problem and then you're like dude I'm
not arguing with you I'm an adult I'm
gonna act like an adult if we can have a
conversation about if you can have hard
conversations with men about hard
subjects and really step back and even
and kind of separate the emotion because
here's the thing let's say you agree to
that and you stay with man and you
suspect he's doing something behind your
back right you think you're not going to
cry you're going to [__] cry and
you're gonna be upset hopefully there's
enough trust and love in that
relationship that you can bring that
pain to him and he's there to Foster you
through it you look to him to help you
through it because you look up to him
because he's there for you because you
trust him because he has proven himself
to you if you can get there with a man
dude I I truly believe that the chances
of divorce at that point are almost next
to nothing also by the way if you are
that type of woman and I'm not trying to
do a campaign for promoting women to let
men cheat but he ain't gonna leave your
ass either
they definitely probably not going to
leave you yeah but they say that men
don't leave their dummies
men don't leave their dummies yeah well
that's your perspective I think those
men probably love those women take care
of them a long time and who's a joke on
because the other women are with the Box
cat the box one and the cats that girl
that girl is probably unadjected to buy
for family vacation so with her mother
on board so you think a woman is better
off staying with a man that takes care
of her provides her instead for her
emotionally and financially yes and
financially than just leaving and
finding because there's this trend on
social media where it's just like if a
person is not treating you right do you
go and walk away do you think that's
perspective no here's here's the thing
what is the likelihood of finding a man
that can actually take care of you
physically emotionally financially is
very low that you're attracted to that
you look up to that's building you up
it's very very low
I'll put it to women like this you're
going to leave me for a man that you
love less that's going to cheat on you
anyway yeah
and I don't look I know it sucks I I
swear to God if I could I would write a
check for a million dollars right now I
would be worth 10x more if that feeling
inside of me that that sexual urge as a
man was gone I'd be like life would be
so much more productive
I don't think it's cool I don't think
it's cute I'm not trying to sound like a
big G none of that [__] I'm telling you
honestly I my whole 20s I dealt with the
pain of leaving women I love because I
want to cheat on them cheat on them I
wish I'd have been in a place where I
could have just told him the truth but I
didn't know any better because I was
young
it's in us it's truly in us I don't I
think the best women in the world are
the one not the best women in the world
the best women in the world are the ones
that do their side of the male and
female Dynamic and understand how the
world actually works and if a man cheats
on you yes it's Gonna Hurt you're gonna
cry he should show up for you but I
don't necessarily think you should leave
because finding a man that's going to
take care of you emotionally and
financially and physically is going to
be hard to come by
you guys in guys and no question what do
you think of girls moving to move into
as in like the girl making the Moon
the move and if you like it how should
they do it if you don't like it why not
my Instagram is Justin when Waller said
okay it happens it happens all day I
mean well I mean for for a wifey not
just because obviously any girl can
slide in your DMs and talk right but
what is a good approach what is a
successful approach for wife and what is
the successful approach for just any
girl sure you wanna take it
so we're talking about for wifey as
opposed to just sliding in the DNA both
but let's
man
well I think uh as far as the the wife
thing's concerned I think that she's got
a just in the context of a relationship
she's got to behave in a way that is
going to make her the most attractive
option that that guy's ever met to
become his wife and the way to do that
is by embodying the characteristics that
that we've discussed so things like you
know modest modesty demunish you know
being Pleasant to be around not being
combatative
showing that she's going to support him
on his mission you know if you're doing
all of those things when in the course
of the dating then what are the best
ways we can support men on their mission
not being competitive I think is one of
them
um but like what's active like what like
like that's that's sort of passive
because it's like not doing something
but what are things that women can like
actively do
I think
um being a stabilizing presence when the
guy come comes back you know I mean
we've talked a lot about cooking and
cleaning and those kinds of things I
mean like we've got ubereats now but you
know I think I think those kinds of
things being nurturing being supportive
in in terms of physical tasks what's the
most supportive thing a woman's done for
you
um they've cooked for me they've you
know they've made woken me up in the
morning maybe breakfast
set out yeah things like that set out
the workspace so that you know making
sure that I'm ready to have a good day's
work you know sort of just just just
really being there on your team but and
not causing unnecessary stress not
causing unnecessary friction it's those
things I think that that are important
that sounds so beautiful but it's so
crazy how people will say that if you do
that then you're a simp and you're weak
if you make your mind breakfast well
I've been fortunate to date some very
feminine women and they've just done
those things because that's how they
wanted to behave you know I've also
dated some women who are less feminine
and they think they didn't but um the
ones that were really dear to my heart
were the ones who who did those things
and like you said they are very very
simple things what do you feel like that
women are the most clueless about
well I think a lot of it is um
the feeling that they need to be there
it needs to be a fight with the man the
whole time you know I mean I was dating
a British girl a few years ago and every
conversation was a battle like she felt
like all the time she had to get one up
on me she had to be the the dominant one
you know in a sort of a girl boss kind
of a way and um and there were times she
could be feminine as well there were
times when she slipped into that into
that space but um in the end I just
thought this is just not an energy that
I want to deal with it's just not an
energy that I feel is is Pleasant
you know so
um can I ask you to be more specific
um because I like to have like this I do
this with my boys sometimes when they
trying to speak to a girl I send I tell
them to write a text
as in my my boys my friends my guys okay
if they ever ask me for advice on uh
girls women how what what should I say
in the first message and I type it for
them they're usually they're quite
successful can you do that for the girls
what would you be me what would you
write on her behalf to get a man to like
her from that first message
well I think it's different we talk
about like sliding into DMS on social
yeah how do you slightly how would you
advise a woman like literally what would
you say to introduce yourself and get a
tick tick tick I'm a fan of commenting
on stories and I think this goes for
either uh on Instagram I think this goes
for either gender actually but I think
if a girl starts following the guy and
then she maybe comments on something she
maybe makes an observation about
something you know like oh I really like
that suit you're wearing or you know
like like I really like the way that you
know if the guys say the guy's giving a
presentation you know he's filming
himself at work he's giving a
presentation I really like the way you
did that that was very cool making some
sort of observation about him I think
would be a good way to initiate the
conversation I mean I have to caveat
this by saying of course it's slightly
different this way around because guys
are going to judge on beauty so the
first thing he's going to do is go and
have a look at her feed and see you know
is she attractive so that's going to
play a huge part but I do think
personalizing it a bit yeah
um and and starting a conversation
talking about something that the guy's
doing is probably better than just
sliding in and going you know hey hello
can I ask Justin I like that I'm curious
I had a question that I asked earlier um
I think you were gone for what are
things that women can do actively to
support men on their mission
so they can they can take
[Music]
it's weird now normally I could talk
without it they can look at a situation
and try to do things proactively I love
nothing more than a woman that's
proactively helping me hey I noticed
this I wash your clothes I fold it on
put them here you know and that's not to
be you know sexist or anything like that
but like a woman that's proactively
trying to help you it is a big deal a
woman that can again sit down and have a
conversation with you you know is a big
deal but you're talking about helping
right yeah well because we always hear
about how
um like you want to be a man's support
system but I think right we don't hear
often like specifics on how to do that
so being really really helpful in that
regard being able to run an error form
or be that you know but I think what's
most important especially for a high
achieving man a high like a high power
man just be his [__] piece man he's
dealing with stress all day he's taking
major risk be the peace you know rub is
back you know do you need anything just
tell them how much especially if he's
helping you in some way or even even if
it's not full charge family house kids
just the you know he's gonna he should
be paying for most of the meals like I
believe in general it's completely
traditional generals I don't believe in
spitting splitting bills I will never
split a dinner bill with a woman and
don't open a [__] door in front of me
but it's those things that you tell him
you appreciate that when it that's when
it goes back to being the hero that's
what makes doing it so worth it so
proactively looking for things to help
him hey I saw that I saw the window the
mirrors in your bathroom had [__] all
over them so I did them for you
little simple [__] because what's real
really so hard for men nowadays is that
look I don't have one of my tenants from
one of my apartment buildings call me up
and say hey Justin you know I really
appreciate you giving me a place to live
if I hit a construction schedule the
customer doesn't come up from Costco
doesn't say you know what we really
appreciate you hitting that schedule
so it's a very thankless life for a man
right as it can be for a woman but
when you're doing these things for a
woman especially when you care about
even this little things like dinners or
trips like if y'all are together right
just telling him how much you appreciate
how hard he's working and acknowledging
the benefit that you're getting will
make him turn circles for you incredible
do you feel like feel like lack of
original people not taking spirituality
seriously is playing a huge role in why
relationships are not working because I
feel like everything we just discussed
now not being combative being submissive
and helping out
um it's all like for me I'm a Christian
it's all in the Bible and I know this
generation doesn't really read the Bible
as much so do you feel like that plays a
role to why people are so clueless of
what it means to be a good wife or a
good husband because I sorry I used to
be one of those very combative people
just always argumentative very toxic it
wasn't until I started to read my Bible
that my whole mindset of what it meant
to be feminine completely shifted and
changing I feel like I've made so many
improvements in my femininity and I
would want women to know the same thing
and would you agree are you like you
know a spiritual in that aspect well
first of all I think a big problem that
we see is that people are trading out
spirituality for practicing religion
whether you believe or not Christianity
particularly in my opinion is the reason
that Society developed in such a way
that it did it gave a very positive
framework for people to live their lives
and they did so and for that reason we
were able to be organized men stopped
acting like caveman you know they still
acted on some Primal things but by and
largely it's what created order and
Order creates the ability to create
strong Society amen as we lose that it
begins to get a little belligerent right
um
I don't feel very
I feel like Christianity is in a bad
place and the reason I think
Christianity is in bad place is because
it doesn't have the backbone to stand up
for itself the way Islam does
in regards to what we're allowing to
have happen in the churches right and
for that reason people are
disenfranchised because they feel the
disingenuousness and the two the kind of
the two-sidedness of Christianity I wish
Christianity would stand up for what it
actually believes in more I agree and I
think people will respect that and get
behind it in a different way and I think
that's why you see Islam doing so well
right now this is not me saying I'm
going to go to Islam you know I grew up
in the south in Louisiana in America I
live in Miami now and it is a [__] show
in both places
um
I do believe that the basis of
Christianity which is very close to
Islam by the way is the way for
societies to live and function
coherently organized and safely and I
think that those values if instilled
into men and women can be very very
helpful in the success of society
families and children that are coming up
yes amen yeah yeah I would co-sign that
I mean I think that
um not just in in terms of being
submissive in a relationship but just
the whole fabric of society since
Christianity has been eroded which has
been going on I mean as you can see you
could say it's accelerated recently but
it's been going on really for you know
half a century or so like since the
second world war you know um organized
religion in this country started to
decline and people didn't buy into it in
the same way that they used to and that
really I think is at the root of all of
these societal problems that we're
seeing amen I did a podcast in a church
today he did a podcast in the church in
a church because it's not a church
anymore
because they're abandoned they're having
to repurpose these buildings there's one
for sale right now it's a hundred and
seventy seven thousand dollars on the
market right now for sale it's been it's
like it's deserted why'd you feel like
Christianity sorry to shift the topic
but why did you feel like Christianity
no longer has a backbone I personally
feel like people have taken the God will
forgive you no matter what too literally
and maybe that's why you know it has no
more backbone because people are going
directly against what's in the actual
word
like there's no such thing as gay
preachers sorry yep it's not because I
hate gay people that's not what the
religion is people feel that you know
what bothers people more than anything
in the world it's not the truth it's
deceit there's deceit in Christianity
right now they're putting gay flags on
churches I just saw one the other day
crazy it's it's a yeah and look it's not
because I hate gay people I don't hate
gay people at all but it's not
Christianity it's not the more it's not
what's in the [__] manual which is
the Bible right now
if we if you have that situation
anywhere else in your life
if you have a job somewhere or somebody
makes a promise to you or somebody does
something for you and and then literally
they don't do that you will feel deceit
it's not it's not the truth that bothers
people it's to seek always
so that's what I think is failing and
then we've created a society in which
from a legal perspective we're not in
America you can literally have children
out of wedlock and cash flow from it the
laws are set up in a way I I said this
I'll show you I think yesterday
it's when I used to grocery shop I would
be in line I'd see a woman sitting there
with six [__] kids she'd have two
buggies one where it was a it was a
Louisiana Purchase Card she's paying in
food stamps the man's gone there's
multiple baby daddies same woman you
know she left them because he cheated
okay well now you have four baby daddies
right and now I'm paying for it with tax
money
you know like the incentive to to have a
nuclear family is gone and they're
pitting men and women against each other
you can make a Facebook account tomorrow
that says you're a 23 year old white
male in the new or black male it
wouldn't matter the things that they
would put in your face to give you
emotion would be completely different
just based off of what you put in there
and why does that make sense well with
technology maybe we need men's backs a
little bit less women are coming up
women are not stupid they're good in the
workplace I'm not saying that they're
incredible my my best people or some of
them are women
but what do you get when you break the
new career family up two people playing
taxes
how you said your highest paid employee
is a woman yeah
um is she married yes and how does she
like navigate that
look they have a very traditional
relationship I don't want to speak on
that too much because they're very close
to me and it's it is work stuff but
she's a very intelligent woman she's a
true Pro she's really good at what she
does he's been doing his job for a long
time they've been married for God I
think 30 years you know they have very
one one of her other Sons worked for me
he's actually in accounting
um
and they're the most based family I've
ever met in fact in a lot of ways
um I think that they're closer to me
than even like that woman is closer to
me my own mother is you know we're tight
I talk to her every day
so um does your husband make more than
her
I don't know you don't know and I don't
want to speculate I'm close to him no
I'm just wondering because you were you
were talking about her and that's very
new by the way oh like I don't think
she's ever made this much money
she's worth every [__] penny yeah
because when you were talking earlier
you're saying it's going to be hard for
me because I'm tall and like I also like
make a lot of money yeah but she's 30
years into a marriage they're past that
you know you know when I really think
the pressure is on 25 to 45. she's past
that like honestly I think she does it
more for me like what traits do you
think in my position I should be looking
for
traits in a man yeah are you not here
you know you already know what you're
looking for yeah no but I'm just curious
do you think like relationships can
never work when the girl out earns the
guy
I think it's very hard yeah I think it's
very very hard because that because
that's the provide part right
you know maybe he can protect you but
you already know that he's a man it's
not you already know you can't whoop his
ass right yeah so then where's the
provide thing
and that's why I don't really believe in
power couples in that way now somebody
could have status and they could have
double status but most often it's not
going to work and a lot of times the
power couples are like famous people
it's not really a power couple I
actually have a friend of mine
his um
his wife got a really solid uh real
estate job and ever since she's been
making that big money they've had
problems and like they're living in
different houses and like this is a big
strong masculine handsome man and just
it just [__] it I have a question sorry
just quickly I'm 23 and I would love to
be married by like 25. I think that's a
great goal by the way thank you women
push that out way further yeah because I
don't want to like let go of my prime
years so what steps do you think I
should take to actually get to that
place where by 25 I'm married
I'm 23 by the way
yeah so
that's probably not going to happen like
right because you're going to at least
date for two years no hear me out yeah
like mathematically that's going to be a
tough tough one right yeah and then you
have to understand too is a lot of times
that people set goals they don't
understand all about like things they're
gonna have to hurdle that's why I think
that trying like I love what you're
doing because you might miss it and get
married at 27 right I like that I like
that from you I feel like you're very
Bass by the way oh thank you very much
I I think that
being the right kind of fabric
okay and what does that look like
everything I was I was speaking to her
about earlier okay as far as like not
having the skin out there kind of stay
up to date on on what's going on the
news
be conservative especially if you want a
man like any man
that's working his ass off is probably
conservative because he doesn't want to
give all his tax money away he doesn't
want to hear about people crying because
he's getting banged every day while he's
winning he's getting arrows put in his
back people are stabbing him in the back
people are not paying them he's got
employees quitting he doesn't want to
hear any crybaby [__] right real men
have real [__] problems and so they
don't like it when people cry just to
get extra when they've done all the damn
work so if you can do that and then do
the things I was talking about earlier
about appreciate hey man listen I really
appreciate that weekend you just gave me
I wouldn't have had it because of you
and it's because you worked so hard and
I really respect and admire how hard you
work to make my life better I love being
with you those kinds of things and then
showing it with little acts of love you
ain't got to clean the whole house if
you don't want to just just wash a
little clothes or wipe off the cabinet
so just show you have that care leave on
that note go kill it today I'm so proud
of you that's the kind of [__] that
makes a man never want to leave a woman
because he's getting return on
investment of all that hard work that
he's putting into you
I think if you want to make a man stay
make him feel appreciated all the time I
think it's a big step it's those little
it really is those little things yeah it
really is yeah we don't want a whole lot
a whole lot just just acknowledge the
fact that I'm out there fighting dragons
for you you know what I'm saying and
then I'm taking all that energy and all
that pain and everything I had to risk
to be able to bring it back to you and
spend a weekend with you in the Bahamas
like just make it known that you
appreciate that so much you know and he
is happy to do it at that point yes
ma'am you know
um you have a lady friend I might start
a new channel just doing this
yeah what's up usually people talk about
men and women shouldn't be friends you
mentioned the lady I agree with that in
your life okay so why why can't she be
your friend and you said that you've got
women in your life that I've got they're
all like you've got girlfriends that do
bring value to your life so do you have
friends that are girls
and would you like that as well would
you like your wife to have male friends
no no no guy friends so you don't rate
that there's no man listen there's no
man find a guy with a a girlfriend
that's 300 pounds good luck and there's
no look any guy that's your friend who
wants to sleep with you so like if if me
and you were friends and you and like
I'm I want to [__] you
I'm gonna be nice long enough to stick
around while you complain about your
boyfriend and give me all the answers to
the test then when we do all those
perfect things I don't personally Run
the game like that because I think
that's [__] [__]
but I'm just hypothetically telling you
if a guy's sticking around he wants to
be your friend he wants to sleep with
you what about the lady that you were
just talking about which one friend that
you mentioned that you know and they're
quite close to you the best one that
works with you so yeah and she's got a
husband do you want to see her dude
let's go first of all she's 50 something
years old okay so there's 20 years
between the age that but yeah I mean and
and I'll tell you something
I got blessed with it thank you I got
blessed with a gift if I sign your
paychecks I do not want to sleep with
you
so maybe like a woman no I can have a
business
yeah but I wouldn't hang out outside of
work okay like when I took all them to
Florida her husband was there okay but
yeah and he's and he's one of the main
ones I want to know is coming right okay
because I'm not I would never disrespect
him I love I love that man of death okay
I make him a part of I include him okay
so so there's dynamics that you can work
with where men and women can be friends
then oh man I she's one of my favorite
people in the whole world okay so that's
good so generally but you have to create
a certain Dynamic that is right and then
you can actually do yeah I don't like it
to be within range I don't particularly
like to hire women don't particularly
like why I'm not no you didn't let me
finish the sentence she's ready
yeah let me finish the sentence I don't
particularly like to hire women that are
close enough in age to me okay that
there could be a thing
all right you know what I'm saying
because it can like look dude I'm the
boss
I'm coming in I'm dressed nice I'm
taking control of every situation we
have over 200 employees yeah like now
bro I don't need it so if you're an
attractive woman then you might as well
just say bye-bye typing guy friends even
if you're older
say again so if you're an attractive
woman even if you're older you should
say bye bye if you're a woman at all I
think you just need to understand if
your man comes to you and says listen I
don't want you to have God friends you
need to truly understand that any guy
that's acting like his friend like like
your friend wants to sleep with you okay
and every other man knows it okay and
anybody that says otherwise is a liar so
what if the man then let's say you're in
a relationship and your guy friend wants
to create a relationship with your
partner because he wants to still be
your friend even if though you're young
as a woman is that big yeah so I'm
around look my friends have me and
Andrew are very close
I've been on sitting at countless tables
with Andrew and Tristan Tate and
Sterling Cooper and they all bring
beautiful stunning women to the table
the only thing that happens when they
get up to pee is I ask them how in the
hell did you land him
that is your job as a friend
you know that's snake [__] I I would
leave my girl in my bank card with the
Tates any day of the week
okay because they and here's why and
this goes back to ethics before you need
them
this happens all the time two guys are
friends
they've been friends 20 years one of
them gets married
the relationship starts getting Rocky
right they get separated
the woman starts whether it be spider
scorn or whatever
the only man that she really has a
relationship outside of her husband was
that friend that dude sleeps with that
girl and he ruined a 20-year marriage I
mean friendship ruined it burnt It To
The Ground they'll never be friends
again why because he's not in enough
abundance he didn't have the ethics to
be in enough abundance to be so proud of
the fact that he could tell there's no
way in hell I have told some seriously
beautiful women to [__] off in my
Instagram inbox so me and Andrew and
Tristan can laugh about it because they
slept with that girl three years ago
there's no [__] way we take pride in
it the only way it's easy to take pride
in it as a man to be in serious
abundance because they don't date
slouches I mean tens and I'll give you
an example there's this girl she
messaged me one time in my inbox
and I'm like hey Andrew I noticed that
you followed this girl he said yeah I
dated her three years ago she's a
[__] perfect got it Andrew said
you're a [__] bye boom that girl has
never had somebody reject her like that
ever
and I like it and so does he because
it's funny it's fun yeah it's fun
because because what other and and
that's why you have to like when we talk
about like you have to have standards in
your life standards for the women in
your life standards for their friends in
your life I don't want a friend that's
not abundant in money and women
because what it'll do what happened to
man B that slept with his friend's
ex-wife
he he was not a bad man he was a
desperate man and he was a desperate man
because he did not have the ethics to
put himself in abundance so he was in a
desert for women so he had to do so he
had a drink
and he ruined something that he could
have had the rest of his life
and you ain't got many friends so as a
single woman
given everything that has been said
about how women they're not your friends
they're jealous of you that they said
that right in general
isn't it really a good idea for a single
woman to actually have more male friends
so that they can tell her that I think
it's a great idea for a single woman to
have married friends
fine so okay so there's there's like
little special married male friends no
okay married female no okay I don't I
don't think a woman should have male
friends like I told zero but
if she wants to lie to herself if she if
she's like hey this guy's my friend but
he wants to sleep with me that's one
thing especially if you're single okay
so what do you what if you get a
boyfriend and he's like nah bro
then if you really love him it won't
even be a problem to get rid of that guy
friend because then it goes back to base
and sit down and have a real
conversation you know in your heart that
God wants to [__] you like come on you
do you do know if you went up to him
you're like hey let's have sex right now
I think some of my guys would find that
very strange they'll be like are you on
drugs yeah as they're like okay
yeah but I was gonna say I asked because
I have a lot of uh male friends he wants
to sleep with you no wait wait but
I believe that
there's almost like at least at least
I'm single right there's a sacrifice
that I make where it's like I'll create
very straight boundaries because I
believe there's a lot of value in me
being especially because I've got
sisters I don't have brothers right I
think there's a lot of value me having
that male energy because my guy friends
are the ones that kind of give me the
right advice and guide me into things
like for example you mentioned of
um don't dress to provocatively that's a
little bit much don't you know like
things like this they kind of put me in
check because they can there are the way
I can reflect my my femininity on
something that is not just a woman's
feminities like a femininity from a
man's perspective because obviously if
you're not in a relationship and if you
don't have your dad around for whatever
reasons or if you don't have brothers
then where do you get that sort of
source and knowledge that sometimes only
a man can give you
well I mean if you were friends with
some couples that that would be the
ideal like what are you saying that'd be
a beautiful thing yeah yeah because that
way you would get some of that from the
the mailing a successful one at that
yeah but you would also get some
exposure to a successful relationship as
well which is kind of like you know
Pearl often talks about you know
learning learning life skills and stuff
I mean that would be the ideal way to do
it so and that's also another really
great way to find the right man because
what will happen is is he's got a friend
that's looking too
and that's how people get put together
you know you meet them in the right
atmosphere oh yeah they all came over
you should come over Jim's coming over
blah blah blah Jim's a stud boom married
bam you're in the atmosphere successful
relationship
so I don't think it's a bad place I'm
going to break up a few friendships
today
[Laughter]
and they're like damn I thought I had
her never did I already know which one I
wanted to be but all you happy I mean
not speculating on all your friendships
but like if you kind of on some level
know the guy wants to sleep with you
that that friendship is not equal is it
it's disingenuous yeah I don't know I
feel like
I mean
I I enjoy sports I enjoy a lot of the
things that you normally do with the
boys right so I almost kind of I don't
sacrifice anything I just simply I'm
very rigid in who I am and how I
interact with men like for example I
always say if there's a um if I'm having
uh you know I'm sitting down with my
friend there's a guy if you do something
to me that is not something that you do
to another guy then I'm like that's not
cool like boys don't sit down hugging
each other for example things there's
boundaries and that allows me to kind of
like take out the things that I do need
the value that there is in knowing a man
on a personal level rather than it
always just be about work do you get
what I mean yeah but I think you're
getting a little bit lost between the
gap between your expectation and your
reality right because your reality is
that he does want to touch you in a
different way than he wants to touch
that other man and you're setting it I
promise you Brothers you are disgusting
yeah they are do that with friends yeah
but but you're believing it but you know
in your heart is not true no to be
honest I do
I mean because of course like yeah duh
so yeah so when he does that and you're
giving him like you might be some of
them show it uh but he did he touched
you in the wrong way no I'm saying I'm
saying
to happen like I have my
for example yeah but he's just trying
not to sit off your creep radar yeah
he's just trying not to sell his creep
radar well then you should cover
yourself up he's paying attention to how
you're dressing he might be trying to
groom you to be wifey you never know I'm
just saying tell me that but like for
example like with my guy friends a lot
of the good things that I like to hear
is when they complain to me about the
girls that they're dealing with and
through that I can understand oh okay
yeah obviously you don't like that the
same way that we're having a
conversation right now do you know how
much knowledge we can take out of
hearing a man is speaking to a man on a
personal level about these sort of
things yeah that's what I but what I'm
saying is like this experience right now
is obsolete really it's not gonna happen
a whole lot but what I think troying out
on the head is that if you can have a
relationship let's say with a girlfriend
and spend time around the couple that
man is a married relationship which
means he's successful at it right
hopefully he's providing protecting and
they're together so you get to see it
right right up close and personal and
then you get to see the dynamic of both
which I think is also really important
and it also puts you in an atmosphere to
be like them which would in this case be
success because you would have a husband
or a partner or whatever two would an
environment really also want to do it
even though he's called yeah dude listen
if I can go to my girl and be like yo
let's have sex with your girl I'm down
don't let me [__] you he wants to
sleep with you as well but the frame is
completely different
the frame's completely different he does
he does but he's not really your friend
he's there and you can get good advice
from a successful man at the kitchen
table or when you're sitting at the
cabinet and she's cooking and y'all are
talking and drinking wine and he comes
in and you can ask his opinion right in
front of his wife it's a different
scenario because you need the right
frame yeah that's fine yeah that makes
sense
I like the answer
boys unless you're putting money in my
pocket we're doing business you can't be
my friend boom
um
I'm gonna Read Super chats really quick
and then we're going to close out the
show
um so if you guys have any final
thoughts anything you want to speak your
piece on um that'll be the time
um also guys make sure you like the
video and subscribe to the channel
that's the most important metric that
YouTube uses to push out these streams
um
oh it's weird this is kind of glitching
oh wait hold on guys sorry one second
also we have a new wife School episode
coming out um what to cook what I would
cook my husband in a day what what is it
oh I did it with Maggie The Substitute
Teacher and what did you cook uh french
toast for breakfast it was sandwiches
for lunch
sandwiches for lunch no no I'm telling
you the same look at the whole staff and
everyone that works here ate it okay
for lunch no I cooked it for everyone
and then it was um how was dinner I
think steak was dinner a steak you don't
like sandwiches I love sandwiches I
don't I don't know
for lunch
sandwiches is like a western thing give
them a pounded Yemen stew okay all right
I got these up Jameson if men are
allowed to cheat cheat which by the way
is being dishonest what are we
suggesting that it is okay to be
dishonest yet dishonesty breeds more sin
another function of a relationship to be
molded for the community uh not your
problem I met your wife while walking my
dog in our neighborhood
when I got laid off the first question
she asked me was how are you feeling she
believed me and at that moment I felt my
love for her grow 100x
Jay I can tell women exactly where to
find these high value men but I will not
make it public Pearl please connect with
me and I will share so you can tell the
ladies off camera and guys we'll agree
once they hear it
um he's got a secret high value man
um it's called the War Room
uh grata Legends um buying her a five
dollar meal at Wendy's is still paying
for it um Disco korba with that being
said though Western culture has been
slowly trying to dismantle the nuclear
family over the years with the
entertainment industry and other factors
in our culture the Bible provides a
solid structure for how to live the
right way um Disco
I love this panel of guests but
hopefully we can continue to create
create these spaces for opening up the
dialogue between men and women's issues
I'm currently trying to get back to my
Christian faith the Bible has been a
very strong case for a man um being the
head of the household
why uh
screamer women born with value and their
main goal is to maintain it men are
nothing until they create their value
and influence other better question if
men are disciples and maintain Society
what is the women to society
uh Let me refresh it real quick just to
make sure I didn't miss any remember
guys it's only over twenty dollars
um okay
oh I need Jay Waller to make the podcast
giving women game he's so well spoken
and navigates women through the red pill
extraordinarily well uh they're already
asking for this podcast
[Music]
um okay final thoughts
um I think it was a really good
discussion today I mean it would be
great if everyone could speak a bit more
I think there was a few people that
didn't speak too much we'll get the
chance to speak as much as they would
have liked but um I think overall it was
a great discussion
I think the male ego is the problem in
society
Society doesn't exist without the male
ego
you will die alone
[Music]
political denalva yeah your turn my turn
so boys if you wanna deny the sauce and
be my friend send me your business
proposal
[Laughter]
um it's been a great conversation today
thanks for having me on again Pearl um
as always I think the mindset thing that
sneako and Justin were talking about
early on is really important regardless
of whatever background we come from
regardless of ethnicity social class the
circumstances that we came up in I think
we've got a we've got one shot at this
guys do you know what I mean we're on
this planet for a few decades you know
like you know not the hugest amount of
time in the world we've got a small
amount of time to really make this work
to build bend the universe to our world
so I think regardless of our initial
circumstances we've got to think right
I'm just going to go out there and do
this and we've all got the chance to do
that you know so um I think there's a
lot of positivity in this message so as
as far as my stuff's concerned just
follow me on YouTube at real Troy
Francis uh real Troy Francis on Twitter
Instagram and Tick Tock as well
thank you
um for myself I've actually learned
quite a lot from you because I'm
normally a headstrong woman but you and
snico have taught me a lot on being more
feminine and I feel like because I'm 19
I do have a lot of time to work on that
so I think if I can benefit from it then
a lot of girls out there can't you but
yeah
um there's so much that's been super
interesting uh it's been a fresher
breath there as well you know a breath
of fresher breath of fresh air yeah like
listening to men talk about
sort of like you know what's a sigma is
it Sigma Alpha
alpha male or is it Sigma I hate all
those words so much I really do
um and and I don't I don't know how to
define them clearly I just what would
you what's the best way of describing
like for example yourself or sneaker or
Troy I think the world would use Alpha
as a placeholder I would never call
myself an alpha I don't think an out an
actual Alpha would ever do that okay I
think a man that's strong and that can
live in conviction and truth and be able
to share his message and strength and
know that if anybody takes advantage of
vulnerability or crush them is the best
way to be and um like I said the
definition of a man to me is a man that
can slit a whole throat and hold a baby
in the same day and be there and sit in
a conversation with somebody who's
willing and truly be there be present
and talk through it like an adult and
with care
so
um that's that's how I look at it I we
only use these labels as a placeholder
in a conversation as far as their actual
value I I wish they didn't exist I hate
them yes yeah and certainly if anyone
applying it to themselves is cringers
yeah
it's very cringy I would never call
myself an alpha I just don't think guys
that are actually Alpha do that it's
interesting how
um I see a lot I see guys using it for
themselves a lot like self-addressing
yeah themselves of like Alpha Sigma male
this is what a sigma does this is what I
know that's a really good sign of
somebody that's probably inflating
themselves and lying to you yeah that's
a really good you want to talk about a
red flag for a man if I'm a woman if
he's calling himself Alpha then he's
probably not no he's probably the kind
of guy you want is just taking care of
[__]
um they don't have to tell you you'll
see it yeah
or Sigma I feel like Sigma is when guys
aren't Alpha but they like want to be so
they made up a new term yeah
I see thumbnails like why sigmas are
better than alcohol yeah I'm like why
you're sitting in your mom's basement
making YouTube videos
first heard about I first heard about
that where
um that term from someone named Sarah
[Music]
um so guys a wife School episode is
finally dropping tomorrow uh Maggie The
Substitute Teacher literally the kindest
sweetest most feminine woman I have
literally met in my life
um came on and gave me a lesson in
wife's school so if you want to see that
check out wife school I believe that's
her third episode also guys like the
video on your way out that's the most
important metric that YouTube uses to
push out these streams
um guys sign up for the fourth
membership tier to get a one-on-one call
with me once a month I can give you a
lot of game on how to run a podcast
um how to recruit whatever you want to
know about running this show um you can
ask me it's going to be the best um
I don't know what it is but it's gonna
be the best money you ever spent in your
life also guys we only have one official
pregame page on Instagram and there's
gonna be a link in the description
um that is a Google form so if you want
to sign up for our events we're going to
do a lot of meetups in the next couple
of months so sign up for the Google form
like the video I